you've been walking for days your body
aches you're dripping with sweat from
the heat of the sun bearing down
overhead and yet you're wrapped up in
layers upon layers of clothing even your
face is covered and you're wearing thick
black goggles so that not a single
centimeter of your body is exposed your
journey has been long and you feel like
you might die from exhaustion or from
overheating due to these multiple layers
of clothes but dying is better than
being exposed you saw it happen when
your entire team
changed the light cannot be trusted not
even for a fraction of a second it's
been like this for years you've learned
and survived through painful experience
many of those you used to know cannot
say the same you've been alone for so
long you might have given up all hope if
it wasn't for the distress signal coming
from a nearby scp foundation containment
facility site 46. any kind of survivors
would be better than nothing no matter
what kind of sorry shape they were in as
long as they were still human you find
your way to an opening in the side of a
mountain and slide into the cave hoping
you weren't spotted the whole world is
crawling with those things now you can't
let yourself be seen as you trudge down
the cave towards the entrance you see
what looks like a huge black snail trail
splattered on the ground leading into
the facility you try to avoid it and
press on you don't even need a key card
to enter the door has been left ajar the
facility reeks of those things but you
can't see any of them you just hope
they've moved on and left some human
survivors in their wake the place looks
abandoned every step you take echoes
through the empty halls when you find
that the elevator's out you take the
stairs all the way down to level b5
ketter containment lucky for you it
seems all the cells are empty now the
horrors that were kept inside of them
have all long since flown the coop you
keep following that slimy black trail
until you find an abandoned office there
are no people here anymore just a broken
barricade some empty medicine bottles
and a bucket that the people inside the
office had apparently been using as a
toilet you breathe a sigh of
disappointment at finding no one alive
here but you're at least relieved to be
out of the sun you can finally remove
your jacket and head wrap with your
uncovered eyes you notice that a nearby
computer terminal is still powered up
you sit down at the desk and turn on the
monitor because of the emergency
procedures put into place in a k-class
scenario like this safeguards no longer
apply you can access all the information
you need up to and including finding out
what actually happened in the dull glow
of a nearby emergency light you see a
dark shape slumping through the halls in
shadow you tense up then exhale as it
slithers off into an adjoining hall
you're safe for now the terminal has
finally loaded and authenticated your
access you're staring at the file for sd
lock's proposal for scp-001
when day breaks it's the only name you
can give the apocalypse your world is
currently experiencing this is one of
the only anomalies in the entire history
of the scp foundation to be given the
apollyon containment class meaning
containment is truly impossible
scp-001 is the most dangerous enemy that
the foundation and planet earth has ever
faced it's always been the principle of
the scp foundation to battle in the dark
so that the civilian world can thrive in
the light but now the light has become
the enemy anyone exposed to any amount
of sunlight for even the briefest period
of time is subjected to the effects of
scp-001
and those effects are beyond horrifying
the scp foundation administrator
released an urgent memo telling
foundation personnel to make their way
to site 19 at all costs because they
need all the help they can get those
exposed to scp-001 in the process are no
longer considered human their new
designation is scp-001-a
these new entities are to be avoided at
all costs but in case of emergencies the
administrator says it is permitted to
cut off parts of your transformed
comrades and eat them to avoid
starvation the memo empathically states
that no attempt should be made to kill
them since you won't succeed you'll just
put yourself at risk when the sun
changed and became scp-008
it instantly affected 6.8 billion
innocent people the second the visible
light touched them whether it was from
the sun itself or even reflected off the
moon their bodies liquefied melting like
candle wax into puddles of living
gelatinous slime this effect isn't
isolated to humans either any biological
entity exposed to sunlight immediately
underwent the same irreversible melting
process into scp scp-001-a
and the horror had only just begun
people transformed into
scp-001a will remain shades of their
former intelligence and personality they
may even try to will their new gooey
mass into a shape resembling their
original form however these individuals
will lose their sense of self if they
come into contact with other instances
of scp-001-a
when they come together zero zero one
dash a instances will bond on a
molecular level waiting up into horrific
giant blobs with only one purpose
integrating more matter into their
bodies that's why they have to be
avoided at all costs you continue to
search the computer terminal for answers
perhaps there was some kind of
contingency plan put in place for this
some way to reverse the effects or at
least escape the nightmare earth has
become
instead you find a series of attachments
linked to the scp-001 file
detailing what seems to be the last days
of the people who'd barricaded
themselves in the facility
most prominent among these were
researcher dr logan igata
her wife ari a security officer named
commander anad and a few others dr igata
had locked herself in the office where
she recorded her final messages to the
world
in the first audio log dr egada and her
companions seemed afraid but hopeful
that there may be some way out of this
situation dr egada reported that most of
the workers at the facility were
transformed during the initial event
their melted bodies had fused outside
the facility and now they were trying to
bust their way back in the defenses had
held so far though and they seemed
confident they would hold long enough
for them to figure out a way to escape
this awful situation you open the second
attachment an incident report and
realize things may not have been as
hopeful as dr regatta let on she
reported hearing the huge mass of melted
creatures hammering on the door outside
again begging for them to come out and
experience the sun with them they wanted
desperately to add to their ever-growing
biomass in order to experiment with what
exactly would happen they sent out one
of their few remaining d-classes wearing
a full protective suit he didn't last
long the huge creature grabbed him with
tentacles made of reconstituted flesh it
began ripping off his protective suit as
he screamed for mercy it was a monster
made of dozens of people and animals he
could never overpower it the second the
sun touched his skin he melted away and
was absorbed by the great mass holding
him in place guns were ineffective
against these
scp-001-a super entities fire would do
no good it seemed that extremely low
temperatures were the only way to slow
the immense blobs down and even then
not permanently there was one ray of
light in the darkness the site director
had a secret tunnel underneath his
office connected to a tram that could
hopefully take them directly to site 19
without risk of scp-001 exposure it was
a good plan and by far the best option
they had available to them but the best
plans often don't work in practice
you open the next attachment on the
terminal this time it's a video feed you
can actually see dr logan igata and she
looks harrowed by what she's experienced
as it turns out while the others
including her wife ari attempted to exit
through the tunnel
something had happened
dr igata heard ari's voice over her
radio but there was something wrong with
it it was too low too guttural and
filled with gurgles
scp-001 had gotten her she was changed
the monster from above had crawled in
through the ceiling it had taken them
all of them and converted them into
something less than human any hope of
escape now seemed gone ari told dr igata
that it would be fine but it was such a
bright beautiful day outside and she was
wasting it locked up inside that office
she tormented dr egatto with shared
memories of their life and love of that
day in the sun where they bound their
lives together the monster with ari's
voice did everything it could to try to
convince her to give up and join them
but she wasn't ready to go just yet you
look away from the screen when you hear
a sound in the corner you see a dark
puddle of some unknown substance and
then some skeletal hands rising out of
it the hands are pulling themselves out
of the puddle followed by a skeletal
face covered in matted hair you have to
stop yourself from screaming until a
flash from a nearby security light makes
the figure disappear it's a normal
puddle once again your mind is playing
tricks on you you open the next
attachment another video and see that dr
igota's condition has deteriorated she
looked pale frantic and thin she was
using a knife to draw her own blood onto
a piece of blood-stained parchment
covered in strange symbols he got a
ranted about her theory what if 001 took
the minds and bodies of its victims but
not their souls through performing some
kind of arcane blood ritual she hoped to
at least rescue and keep the soul of ari
even if her mind and body were lost you
open the next attachment it seemed that
agata's ritual worked but not in the way
she hoped the twisted soul of ari driven
mad by scp-001 had taken over the file
it begins corrupting the text of the
scp-001 file into crazy ranting about
how futile it is to fight it then cuts
to an even more frightening video feed
dr igata in her sleep tossing and
turning in a makeshift bed in the corner
of her office the camera approaches her
in first person and lingers over her
sleeping body an oily skeletal hand
reaches past the camera and runs its
fingers through dr igoda's hair it's
that exact same hand you saw reaching
out of that black puddle earlier you
must have seen ari's lingering spirit
with a lump in your throat you open the
next attachment and watch the video you
see dr igata now truly broken she'd been
haunted by ari's demonic spirit for a
long time now and it has clearly taken
its toll she is waving around a handgun
while she speaks she now believes there
is only one way to escape but not like
this she doesn't want the gun to draw
attention to her body she doesn't want
to become part of that mass even if she
is dead she opens a drawer on her desk
she's recording at and places the gun
inside dr regatta then apologizes to her
loved ones who are likely long since
dead or assimilated and turns off the
recording for the last time in that
moment you realize there's a single
drawer in the desk in front of you when
you reach forward and open it you see
the same handgun dr egada was holding is
laying inside you pick it up and study
it weighing your options perhaps there
truly is no other way out then you see
an update on the file one more
attachment has been added while you were
studying the gun you feel your heart
pounding in your chest as you reach
forward and open the attachment the text
has been changed entirely the file on
scp-001
is now a poem an ode to the sun
and to the love they shared then a video
file spontaneously opens itself on the
screen
it's a video of you shot from behind
you see those oily skeletal hands
reaching for you in the dark
just like they did with dr igata in that
moment you panic and fire them behind
you hoping to scare off the spirit
instead the sound of the gunshots
attracts something far worse the immense
blob of screaming melted flesh charges
towards the office you try to barricade
the door but it is not enough the flesh
seeps and bursts through and grabs you
in its meaty tentacles you scream and
try to escape but it won't save you
nothing will save you the flesh carries
you upstairs out through the empty halls
out into the cave you can see the light
in the distance as the blob buries you
towards it you won't be alone for much
longer in fact you won't be alone ever
again it's tough to know how we might
respond to a true disaster what might
any of us do when the world turns upside
down and nothing makes sense anymore
what if the simple act of stepping
outside into the sunlight became the
deadliest thing in the world we've
delved into this horrifying notion
before with scp-001
when day breaks or sd lock's proposal
one of the most nightmarish xk class end
of the world scenarios ever devised mr
rogers once said that the best thing to
do in times of trouble is look to the
helpers no matter how dire things become
there will always be those taking up the
difficult work of putting their
community back together firefighters
emergency medical services soup kitchens
there are so many different kinds of
helpers out there unfortunately most of
them would be the first to go once the
sun's rays turned on us all the
firefighter attempting to put out a
blaze would melt into a puddle of goo
the emt running out of an ambulance
would melt the second his feet hit the
pavement when doom and destruction are
everywhere who is left to help perhaps
someone who has always dreamed of saving
humanity from a great plague but is
trapped inside with no sunlight in sight
when the whole world has grown sick
humanity forever changed into something
terrible we just might need a doctor
today we're looking at what happens when
a dedicated physician meets his greatest
challenge yet we've discussed scp-049
many times before he's a humanoid entity
standing roughly 1.9 meters in height
resembling a man dressed in the garb of
a medieval plague doctor he is clad in
thick dark robes and a ceramic mask that
tapers into a long sharp beak though it
may look like a costume these adornments
are actually part of the entity's body
scp-049 wants one thing to cure
humankind of a mysterious pestilence the
nature of which has never been entirely
clear sadly his work tends to do more
harm than good he can kill with a single
touch and his attempts to cure human
subjects result in malformed zombies
instead he carries around a black
doctor's bag capable of holding an
impossible amount of medical implements
which he uses to perform his work though
his actions tend to result in more harm
than good the plague doctor seems to
genuinely care about his patience their
well-being and curing them of the
illness he believes to be ravaging their
bodies
scp-049 is singular in his obsession
with eradicating the plague he so often
speaks of and he will not stop until he
has done so but what does a doctor do
when there are no more patients left to
treat when humanity has been wiped out
and the pestilence is gone for good
let's peek in on the doctor in his
containment cell and see what he's up to
it appears that he's working on
something or perhaps it's better to say
someone but what is this new creation it
looks too small to be a human too
human-like to be an animal it looks too
much
like him has it finally happened has the
plank doctor begun to reproduce himself
it seems the answer is yes but not in
the way you might think since it appears
what he has created is a plush version
of everyone's favorite masked malady man
that's right the plague doctor has
created something special and now for
the first time you can have a plague
doctor of your very own by going to
scp-swag.com and ordering one right now
and with this one you don't have to
worry about waking up to find that
you've been converted into a walking
zombie-like shell of your former self no
this nearly 10 inch tall plush which
comes complete with his own removable
doctor's bag is a soft squeezable
version of the scp-049 that we all know
and love
or fear put him on your shelf carry him
with you in your own bag or set him on
your desk so that you always have
someone to discuss your own theories of
what exactly the pestilence is we just
can't promise that he'll divulge any
secrets since this little plague doctor
seems especially tight-lipped we know
you'll love him as much as we do though
so go to scp-swag.com and order one for
yourself right now supplies are limited
so don't wait but back to the taller and
more mobile plague doctor the doctor sat
in his containment cell as he did every
other day of his captivity doing his
best to keep busy the scientists of the
scp foundation were small-minded they
did not comprehend the gravity of his
work the necessity of ridding the world
of the pestilence he forgave them for
their ignorance for they did not know
what they were doing instead he kept his
mind on the goal the duty he had as a
physician and a man of the sciences just
as many scientists had done in the past
when their work was unappreciated
copernicus was persecuted for his model
of the universe and his knowledge that
the earth revolved around the sun jonas
salk for his controversial invention of
the polio vaccine that saved countless
lives
scp-049 would be remembered fondly by
history for his contributions even if
his contemporaries did not understand
his vision and so in spite of the
suspicion and doubt that surrounded him
at this foundation that should have been
all for groundbreaking research the
doctor carried on with his work he sat
on the floor of the cell his bag opened
next to him from its endless interior he
withdrew syringes bottles of viscous
liquids tissue samples suspended in jars
and a stainless steel table upon which
he could place it all today he would
perform a new round of tests on samples
he had been able to extract from
previous patients before he was thrown
into this unjust imprisonment these
doctors men he had once viewed as
colleagues had not brought him a new
test subject in quite some time a guard
had muttered something about it being
too costly to keep wasting perfectly
good cows on him simpletons fools
luddites beating their fists against
their own chests in the face of true
progress their small minds were of no
concern to him the doctor placed his
tools on his work table and began to
take out the samples an ear a piece of
skin taken from the bottom of a foot a
section of a liver and most exciting of
all the frontal lobe of a human brain
indeed it would be a fruitful day of
investigation into the mysteries of the
great dying he was just pulling a
scalpel from his bag when his
concentration was suddenly interrupted
by the sound of a blaring siren he set
his tools down and looked up that's
sound it signified trouble at the
facility but surely it would be over
soon once the issue had been dealt with
outside his cell he could hear the
thundering footsteps of guards running
past shouting at one another too quickly
for him to understand one man stepped
over to peer into 049 cell making sure
he was still contained most likely my
good fellow the doctor called out
reminding himself to speak in the king's
english so the man could understand
would you be so kind as to enlighten me
what is the trouble if anyone has been
injured i would be happy to offer my
assistance
the man did not respond his attention
grabbed by something further down the
hall that the doctor could not see wait
he cried but the guard had already
disappeared the siren continued to blare
assaulting his senses with its shrill
tone in the distance he could hear
screams surely there was a dire
situation at hand had that damnable
reptile escaped again he approached the
door to his cell listening for further
information there was no roaring no
sounds of walls crumbling there was only
that blasted alarm and the screams of
unadulterated fear and agony very
curious and quite troubling
scp-049 tried to open the door knowing
that it was futile he had never been
able to escape before why would that
change now still a scientist must repeat
his efforts in order to gather new data
so he thrust his shoulder against the
door attempting to break it down it did
not budge instead an automatic
containment measure was triggered
releasing lavender scented gas into the
room in an attempt to calm the doctor
down he did love the scent it reminded
him of gentler times long ago he took a
deep breath imagining fields of purple
flowers swaying in the summer breeze
that was the world he fought for not the
flawed human beings that opposed him not
this sterile facility packed with the
ignorant for now he would return to the
work if they did not desire his help
there was nothing more to be done
sometime later perhaps hours perhaps
days he could not be certain when there
was no sunlight to gauge the time by the
alarm fell silent the doctor stopped his
ministrations and listened as the alarm
had stopped so too had the screams in
fact the whole facility seemed to have
gone completely eerily silent hello he
called out but there was no response
save for a clicking sound now that was a
sound he had heard before normally it
signified the arrival of armed guards
who would strap him into a harness knock
him out and take him somewhere else it
was the sound of the door to his
containment cell unlocking but there was
no one there could it be grabbing his
faithful bag as scp-049 cautiously
pushed against the door it swung open
revealing a darkened vacant hallway gone
were the harsh fluorescent lights the
d-class personnel mopping blood stains
off the floors the doctors hurrying by
with clipboards in hand everyone was
gone from what he could see at least he
would have to investigate further in
order to know for sure a scientist never
assumes until they have all of the
available information after all so
scp-049 walked the halls of the
seemingly abandoned foundation site
expecting to be interrupted at any
moment by an adversary in a white coat
who would usher him back to his prison
but the interruption never came as he
rounded the corner past one of the
containment facilities a familiar voice
called out to him excuse me please could
you help me open the door zero four nine
stopped and peered into the room it was
the possessive masks room scp-035
the doctor opened the door and there it
was the porcelain mask grinning at him
from its glass case thick black liquid
oozed from its eyes and wide open mouth
oh wonderful it's you the mask gleefully
enthused my good man you gentlemen and
scholar would you please release me from
this awful case zero four nine paused
considering the potential ramifications
of this action no doubt you've noticed
that things have changed around here the
mass continued the foundation is
different now the old rules have gone
out the window hmm so it would seem the
doctor replied i will not wear you
understood i will only release you from
your cage and for that i will be
eternally grateful the mask promised the
doctor approached the glass case in
several quick strides and with one
gloved fist broke through the glass
thank you old friend the mask cried out
now take me with you the doctor shook
his head i have more pressing matters to
attend to at the moment if it is true if
they have all gone then this facility is
in dire need of a new head researcher at
his words the mask's visage changed the
cheerful smile warping into an
exaggerated frown and you think you're
the man for the job how embarrassing how
truly tragic bite your tongue the doctor
retorted ah but i don't have one some
physician you are the mask taunted
unwilling to deal with the porcelain
fiends nay saying any longer the doctor
turned and swept out of the room now was
not the time for such verbal sparring he
had so much to do
this whole facility could be his new
workshop his laboratory and he would
need assistance to help him manage it
but who was qualified enough loyal to
the cause armed with sharp wit and a
body free of pestilence as he made his
way through the pitch black halls he
felt something nudge his leg he glanced
down uncertain what he would find and
saw a tear-drop shaped orange creature
nudging him affectionately gazing up at
him with one large unblinking eye next
to his other leg a mustard yellow
creature the same shape and size was
rolling toward him are you friend the
foe the doctor asked the creatures
continued to nudge against his legs
seeming to want something attention
perhaps he bent down and patted each
creature gently they rolled around his
feet in circles making a delighted
babbling sound ah companion it is well
then come along as he continued his path
the little creatures rolled after him
keeping close to his heels suddenly they
began to babble loudly in a panicked
tone swarming around the front of his
feet as if to stop him is there a danger
here my ocular friends the doctor asked
from the cell up ahead a voice cried out
in french help please i'm so hungry the
doctor rushed to the door opening it to
reveal a behemoth of a man with a large
rounded chin and jaw and deep-set eyes
that peered down at him the man grinned
at the doctor with impossibly large
teeth thank you sir i was sure i would
die in there as he stepped out into the
light the doctor could see this giant
was dressed in a military uniform are
you a military man the doctor asked yes
i was a soldier in the french army once
the giant replied before i became the
greatest detectives the world has ever
known the doctor clapped his hands
delightedly his eyes glittering from
within his mask intelligence and loyalty
not to mention strength you my good man
are everything i have been searching for
would you do me the honor of working as
my assistant i have a great deal of
research to do and could make use of a
man with your many talents the giant
tipped his hat politely to the doctor it
would be my honor sir you may call me
fernand he reached out for a handshake
but the doctor shook his head it would
be best if i did not but it is a
pleasure to make your acquaintance he
glanced down at the ipods still
scattering about anxiously see there is
nothing to fear here unless i don't find
something to eat soon fernand quipped
and so the doctor continued on his way
with fernan and his new pets in tow this
was an excellent advancement but he
would need a great deal more help if he
was to effectively run the foundation he
recruited two other anomalies with a
mind for scientific research a small
bird with a deafening voice and a doctor
himself and an eloquent sea slug with
years of hunting and adventuring
experience it was a relief to find
fellow intellectuals here as the
ever-increasing band of anomalies
approached the basement ferdinand peaked
up noticeably something smells wonderful
just beyond this door fernand opened the
door and led the group into a treasure
trove of corpses they had found the
foundation's morgue rows and rows of
drawers filled with test subjects and
food for ferdinand it was everything the
doctor could have possibly wanted my
dear fedeman take as many as you can
carry and follow me to the laboratory
the doctor declared tallyho
dr spenco added the doctor set up shop
in one of the many expansive on-site
labs though the electricity was out he
could still get a great deal of use out
of it there was so much space in here so
many more resources than his tiny cell
had within a matter of hours he had set
up rows of ivs pumping out his serums
into test subjects reanimating them into
more lab assistance the newly revived
corpses shambled around the lab bringing
him bone saws and forceps vials and
needles of all sizes as the doctor
worked harder than he had in years the
others were less help than he had hoped
but with so many newly treated patients
to share the workload he hardly noticed
all of these poor souls victims of the
pestilence no doubt and he had all the
time in the world now to cure them
before long the once vacant halls of the
foundation were filled with the slow
plotting footsteps of his patients
dragging their swollen limbs across the
ground blinking their milky white eyes
at the chaos outside of the windows of
the facility as 049 was absorbed in his
work the rest of the escaped anomalies
began to realize that their freedom had
come at a cost where there had once been
friendly yellow sunlight beaming down on
a lush green world there was now an
angry red fire in the sky and a
landscape covered in strange gelatinous
masses roving and oozing and moaning as
one they had escaped from their cells
but they were still trapped their prison
had just gotten larger the doctor had
not yet noticed this unfortunate truth
so focus was he on treating the patients
they had recovered from the morgue at
least the ones that had not been given
to ferdinand to satisfy his mammoth
appetite however a week later the doctor
was horrified to discover that there
were no more corpses left no more
patience to cure he stood in the empty
morgue looking from drawer to drawer for
just one body they had missed proof that
his work was not over so soon what's the
matter doctor a sardonic voice behind
him said he turned to find
scp-035 attached to the face of a
mannequin i see you procured the body he
noted no thanks to you the mask replied
oh how sad a doctor with no one to treat
what will you do now that you have no
purpose in life i wonder there will be
more the doctor insisted there is an
entire world out there that needs my
help the mask laughed in disbelief
[Laughter]
you mean you haven't noticed there's no
word left to help it's all gone to hell
take a look for yourself the doctor
rushed to an upstairs window and gazed
down at the destruction outside the
painful red sunlight the rubble where
there were once buildings the masses of
soft gooey matter that aimlessly
squelched along the ground no he put a
hand to his beak shaking his head it
can't be but it is said the mask
standing behind him its face was locked
in a grin delighted to see him suffering
so your life's mission gone just like
that the doctor's knees went weak as he
tried to take it all in perhaps the mask
was right he had no purpose anymore but
then ferdinand's voice boom from below
doctor we need your assistance
downstairs quickly the doctor followed
his assistant's cries and saw what was
so urgent one of the blob creatures an
entity he knew must have once been a
human being had found its way inside the
facility fernand stood back from it
afraid to touch its slimy surface but
scp-049 did not see a monster there
oozing across the floor he saw someone
who is sick desperately ill and in need
of help in need of a doctor do not be
afraid my friend he sat down his bag and
reached inside as his reanimated helper
swarmed around the blob creature you are
not well but i'm going to help you the
great dying may have been out of his
grasp but if the scene outside the
window was anything to go on there was
still a plague raging across the earth
and he was going to find the cure don't
forget go to scpswag.com to order a
plague doctor plush of your very own
that's
scpswag.com it was such a normal morning
almost comically uneventful for the
first time in what felt like forever the
morning newscasts had very little to say
they covered fashion week some protests
in the capital a new health craze
sweeping the nation a funny viral video
of a dog eating a pancake the
inspirational story of a young boy from
the midwest beating cancer a minor
political scandal out of tallahassee
florida that nobody would remember in a
week a round of interviews with an
expert who'd written a new book about
the long-term effects social media might
have on our children none of them knew
back then that long term was a luxury
they couldn't afford people went to work
to school some took the day off plenty
took walks or jogs deciding to exercise
outside for a change after all it was
such a beautiful sunny day out what a
terrible shame it would be to waste the
light indoors people were sleepwalking
so placidly blissfully unaware of what
was rattling down the tracks towards
them it was an uncharacteristically slow
day down at site 19 there hadn't been
any containment breaches in over a week
a couple of new anomalies had been
brought into containment one safe class
and one euclid but neither were the kind
that was likely to bring the scp
foundation any trouble right now the
biggest threat facing their employees
seemed to be boredom and they definitely
take that over any other members of
their rogues gallery dr bright poured
himself a mug of nice hot coffee and
decided to watch some tv in the break
room just to pass the time the president
of the united states was giving a press
conference on the white house lawn
surrounded by microphones it was really
nothing special just the same inane
babble about how he was going to fix the
deficit and with inflation on the rise
we'd all need to work on being more
fiscally responsible the immortal
foundation researcher sipped his coffee
these normal boring problems felt like
the perfect escape from the insanity he
needed to deal with every day at the
foundation the president was saying
something about the importance of
families and about farmers being the
nation's real backbone when something
happened there was an odd shift in the
quality of the light dr bright barely
registered it maybe it was something to
do with the cameras however things
started to get stranger the president's
speech began to slur as though he'd just
been pumped with enough morphine to take
down an elephant but it wasn't just that
he was sweating buckets too wet patches
expanded all over his suit and
perspiration was dripping off his skin
dr bright was in suspense was he about
to watch the president have a stroke
live on air would he be called in to
replace him yet again but no the
situation unfolding was far far worse
the president of the united states
slumped forward over his podium while
the reporting corps screamed his face
slopped off his skull like melting wax
the president's words slurring off into
infinity it was the worst a u.s
president had looked on film since
scp-1981
dr bright dropped his coffee cup it
tumbled and shattered onto the ground
below the camera fell as the operator
screamed it pointed down into the crowd
where the reporters were shrieking in
pain and terror steam coming off their
bodies with a sudden intense climb and
heat they were all melting all of them
were melting before his very eyes
broadcast out to how many people it
would be the mother of all containment
nightmares little did dr bright know
that wasn't even the half of the true
horrors unfolding alarms went off across
every containment site in the world
nescp foundation employees unlucky
enough to be standing outside at the
time were lost in the rapidly unfolding
horrors they screamed as the sun cleaved
their atoms apart reducing them into
semi-liquid states without the mercy of
death people lucky to be just out of the
sun could only watch as those less
fortunate disintegrated across the
ground in unholy shrieking puddles never
had such a normal day been thrown into
such terrifying chaos in so little time
billions of voices cried out at once as
the sun changed in the sky above them
since the dawn of humanity it had given
us everything white to baskin warmth to
keep us safe and the life of the plants
and animals that kept us fed it had been
worshipped as a god by countless
cultures over thousands of years one
great mother to all of humanity and now
that mother was drowning us in the
bathtub and perhaps the most frightening
part of all it was for seemingly no
reason
no reason
at all the scp foundation was forced to
now break their silence forever the
masquerade the veil it melted along with
so much of humanity they took over every
communications channel in the world and
did what they could to inform people on
how to get out of harm's way stay inside
wrap yourself in sun shielding clothing
and only move at night air travel is
preferable if possible if you can make
your way to one of the scp foundation's
secure sites their only chance of
preserving humanity and figuring out how
to reverse this new nightmare now more
than ever the scp foundation would be
humanity's only hope until of course
there was another terrifying twist in
the tale while those who were melted
into piles of living flesh sludge were
sadly assumed to be lost even the
foundation didn't expect the transformed
humans to become a threat in and of
themselves just as their bodies were
melted so were their minds they became
slaves cultists of the growing tyrant
hanging up above some would coagulate
into huge fleshing masses horrifying
threats that would seek out victims
overpower them and drag them out into
the light to be absorbed and transformed
even those hiding inside foundation
containment centers weren't safe these
behemoths of melted flesh would find
their way in using their many twisted
voices to slowly break the minds of
their victims then gather them up with
great flesh tendrils and yank them out
into their doom little by little the
numbers of humanity dwindled it looked
like we had a bright future ahead of us
and in this particular context that's
far from a good thing survivors for
whatever time they had left would
forever remember this walking nightmare
the foundation dubbed it
scp-001 to reflect its ultimacy but to
everyone else it had a different name
when dave rakes in a world where
anything but darkness will kill you is
there anywhere left on earth that's
truly safe from the horrors of scp-001
five months into the never-ending horror
of the solar singularity alice spooned
herself a bowl full of warm swedish
meatballs delicious she was part of an
investigative detail from a nearby
community deep within the bowels of the
only truly safe place for human beings
on planet earth
scp-3008 also known as the infinite ikea
no sun had ever shown in there only the
lights which fizz and flicker far above
everyone inside thinks of it as a prison
little do they know what's left of
humanity out there would kill to be
inside the sanctuary alice had a team of
10 with her their mission was simple
continue the mapping effort of the area
surrounding their community and collect
rations for the rest of the camp it was
dangerous work especially as knight drew
clothes but there were certain rewards
when they reached a feeding station they
were able to enjoy fresher food than
anyone else all they needed to do was
wager their lives for it to alice it
seemed like a fair trade her lieutenant
darcy kept watched to the north he and
several others wielded makeshift spears
made from curtain rods and clubs
fashioned from bed posts knives
scavenged from the kitchen section hung
from their belts in makeshift holsters
during the day they were little more
than a precaution at night it could mean
the difference between life and death
speaking of darcy kept a close watch on
a member of staff it was a lanky
faceless monster in that garish uniform
with a bulbous oversized head and long
arms hanging slack like pulled taffy
dragging its knuckles along the ground
as it stumbled along darcy thought it
darkly funny how stupid they could look
in the daytime like crash test dummies
rejected from the assembly line
bear stood close by he never gave any of
them his real name so they took to
calling him bear because he was big
hairy and would probably tear you to
shreds if you got on his bad side he
wielded the largest club of all a
customized creation with sharp objects
sticking out of it on all sides it
cleaved the heads of many staff members
off their bodies bears seemed to relish
the task of putting those monsters down
for him it was easy and fun that's why
he was an essential asset on these
missions a berserker most of the grunts
shoveled as much food as they could
carry an ikea branded tupperware and
coolers the more they gathered the
longer it would take for them to be
forced out beyond the safe walls of the
haven they built inside this swedish
flat pack hell they all made do with
what they had in here it was all they
could really do two members of the team
were unaccounted for cyril and joseph
would pass for reconnaissance experts
down here they seem to have an innate
sense of direction as though they were
somehow in tune with the ikea itself
they would be sent out on scouting
missions searching for resources food
other survivors and most prized of all
potential escape routes it was a dream a
fantasy that someday one of them would
find the exit and lead the rest of them
to salvation through it alice had been
trapped in the infinite ikea for six
years going on seven now she had long
since given up on dreams of escape all
they could do was accept their situation
get used to it and just try to survive
under these circumstances but those
circumstances were about to change
everyone looked up when they heard
panicked breathing it was cyril just
cyril the party clutched their weapons
just that little bit tighter unsure of
what had happened their rules were clear
scouting duos must never ever separate
under any circumstances getting lost in
the store and being isolated when the
lights went out would be a death
sentence so if cyril was returning alone
frightened tears streaking down his face
then something truly awful had happened
he told alice and the rest of the group
that something had attacked him and
joseph when alice told him that was
impossible that the staff wouldn't show
active aggression until lights out until
someone attacked them first cyril shook
his head and let out a heaving sob he
told them that the creature that
attacked them wasn't a member of staff
it was something else entirely something
he'd never seen inside the ikea before a
true monster whatever this creature was
it moved around a corner incredibly fast
it spoke in a way that was almost human
but something was off about it something
that sent a chill down cyril's spine
just thinking about it he recalled that
the creature was large and blob-like
flesh-colored with long grasping
tendrils that whipped and flailed
unnaturally these tendrils had wrapped
around and grasped joseph he hadn't been
quick enough the two of them were too
shocked by the sight of it to react in
time and then it was already too late it
grabbed joseph and yanked him off into
an adjoining aisle cyril still
remembered his haunting screams getting
quieter and quieter as he moved further
out of sight on some level everyone
hoped that cyril was lying it was
preferable to believe that he himself
had snapped and murdered joseph for some
unknown reason as opposed to some new
stronger and even more dangerous
creature that was now inside the ikea
was this some kind of upgrade as they
acclimated to the environment adapted
gotten better at surviving here had the
ikea in turn created deadlier
countermeasures to destroy them all just
when you thought you had a handle on
things but if cyril was telling the
truth and there was some kind of
creature lurking in the store or
potentially more than just one then they
could be in danger just standing here
they gathered up the group along with
any supplies worth taking and set off
back to their community they would need
to deliver the bad news so they could
potentially prepare for the worst it was
just one of the many communities housed
within
scp-3008 many have theorized over the
years that the infinite ikea acts as a
kind of nexus point for ikeas all across
the multiverse accounting for the truly
insane number of people who have gone
missing without a trace into the
building over the years there were
children who had been born in the ikea
raised in the ikea known nothing but the
ikea nobody knew an exact number for
sure but it was more than possible that
the population of a small country
resided within its walls sometimes
communities would fracture and fall
apart occasionally due to a lack of
resources or infighting other times due
to an overwhelming attack from the staff
that physically destroyed the settlement
often leaving many of its members dead
in the process those who weren't picked
off while wandering the store in the
following days would likely integrate
into other nearby communities as
refugees life was cruel in the infinite
ikea by the time alice and her party
returned to their community it was
almost lights out they spoke to the
community leaders and informed them of
joseph's tragic disappearance as well as
this awful new creature that cyril
claimed had taken him they thought it
best not to inform the rest of the
community tonight it might hurt their
focus and cause unnecessary panic alice
agreed to join the watch that night she
could feel something wrong in the air
even more so than usual there was
something terrible in this anomalous
ikea alice stood atop the furniture wall
with several other rangers as the lights
flickered off the distinctive calls
sounded across the store from the
activated staff members
[Music]
it was almost soothing in its
familiarity compared to the frightening
thoughts that cyril had left swimming
through her mind the staff she could
handle it was at least the devil she
knew and there were worse beasts than
the devil out there she knew it in her
bones they killed a few staff members
that happened to wander towards the
community and began beating their
deformed fists against the walls all
standard procedure but as alice eyes
adjusted to the darkness she saw a huge
shape in the distance it looked like a
mountain that breathed a huge wobbling
mass of flesh moving impossibly fast for
a creature of its size it was so much
vaster than the creature that cyril had
described earlier was this a different
one or had it simply gotten bigger
either way it was coming straight
towards them the community came alive in
sudden panic every able-bodied adult
grabbed their weapons and prepared for
the fight of their lives behind the wall
whatever this monster was they needed to
kill it as quickly as possible before it
destroyed everything they built sadly
for everyone inside the community this
was one fight that none of them were
prepared for the beast crashed into the
furniture wall crushing it inwards
people struck at the monster's immense
and terrible flesh with their weapons
making awful wet slats but seeming to
cause no lasting impact it just kept
rolling in grasping everyone it could
with its long sinewy tendrils but the
horrors were only just beginning with
the wall destroyed the staff began to
pour in chanting in monstrous unison
it was a massacre perhaps one of the
worst that the inside of the infinite
ikea had ever seen
while the community battled the giant
flesh beast the forces of the staff
swarmed and overwhelmed them darcy was
tangled in the nightmarish tentacles of
the beast bear was surrounded by a truly
insurmountable number of staff members
each one bawling their terrible fists
and beating him to death somewhere cyril
screamed though his scream was soon cut
short alice watched in horror as
everything she'd known was destroyed
alice realized her friends were dead and
her community was in ruins she grabbed
her spear and did the only thing she
could she ran
she ran from the lost cause that had
once been her life tears running down
her cheeks what had even happened what
the hell had that great monster been the
ikea's trump car she ran aimlessly for
as long as she could then walked and
eventually limped she went on for hours
getting lost deeper and deeper into
unknown territory
she'd stop when she was dead why not she
had little left to live for but like the
holy grail when she eventually truly
gave up and stopped looking for
salvation it found its way to her as she
turned a corner down a mysterious aisle
she saw something that she hadn't seen
in years glass double doors she stifled
the sob could it be the way out of here
after all this time and it was
the world escape she lost everything but
regained this outside dawn was breaking
after years the great red sun it was the
most beautiful thing she'd ever seen in
her life she took a deep breath
smiled and stepped into the light it has
been one month since the end of the
world 30 long days since stella had
watched her husband dissolve in front of
her one minute mowing the lawn like it
was any other lazy afternoon and the
necks collapsing into a useless pile of
flesh and jelly the end didn't come like
she always thought it would with
hellfire raining down and pale riders
galloping across the land on horseback
it began in the kitchen with her humming
a song to herself mixing up a pitcher of
lemonade before she rejoined her family
in the sunshine then they were gone lost
forever when the sun
turned wrong she didn't even have time
to grieve them properly before the
threat turned on her as the creatures
that had once been her husband her son
and her daughter swarmed the door
slamming their new bodies against the
wood with wet slaps calling out to her
in warped voices begging her to step
back outside she covered her ears and
wept for hours until she had no tears
left to cry it didn't take long for
stella to figure out that whatever had
happened to her family it was happening
all over the world the small town she
had known and loved had transformed into
a hellscape a maze of monsters and
deadly light she retreated underground
two old mine shafts and tunnels left
abandoned decades ago when the local
cold trade had dried up there she
quickly discovered that she wasn't the
only one with that idea there were
others survivors who had managed to make
their way down into the dark away from
the horrors above there weren't many and
she could never get too attached to the
ones she did meet in case they too were
lost to the sun but as the days were on
in the tunnels she found herself forming
a small group of stragglers not quite a
family but something that could be one
day and definitely much better than
going it alone there was stella of
course using her background as an
elementary school teacher to keep
everyone on track and working together
then there was brian a former volunteer
firefighter whose training and skills
with an axe came in handy more than once
there was trina a teenage girl who had
been babysitting when everything went to
hell who had a knack for evading the
flesh monsters and making supply runs
and then there was doris former military
nurse and current de facto team medic
sharp and capable in spite of being in
her late 70s they were brave people
brilliant and refused to give up others
came and went spare survivors they
picked up as they navigated their way
raiding the ruins of grocery stores and
hospitals but they always wound up
leaving again or worse something would
go wrong and the sunlight would claim
another victim but the four of them
stayed together stronger with their
combined skills willpower and ability to
sleep in shifts and keep an eye out for
trouble after some time in the tunnels
the group had come across a massive
abandoned facility none of them could
determine where it came from or what
organization might have run it but it
appeared to have been some kind of
research lab it was isolated cut off
from outside influences better than any
of their previous hideouts had been
whoever had once worked here had cleared
out or been taken out in a hurry but in
their place they had left behind rations
medical equipment emergency generators
and clean drinking water there were
enough supplies to keep the group going
for months if they rationed carefully
and so they settled in the abandoned
research facility whatever it once was
became their makeshift home this
unexpected sanctuary was cut off from
the rest of the world clinical cold
lonely but a safe place for them to rest
their heads now it had been a month
since this all began stella shook her
head at this realization the passage of
time feeling almost meaningless at this
point what did a month even mean anymore
what was a day when she couldn't even
see the sun rise and set as she sat
there warming herself by the side of a
foraged space heater she thought about
missing the stars the moon the promise
of the cosmos a time when the vast open
sky was an invitation to dream instead
of something to hide from that time was
gone now there was nothing to do but
mourn it and carry on if not for her
than for the others they had all found
ways to keep busy in this new place
trina took to exploring the empty halls
the laboratories filled with strange
equipment the small rooms that looked
like prison cells or police
interrogation rooms she had cooked up
some theory about it being a government
facility like something out of an old
episode of the x-files brian had found
an on-site library filled with history
books and scientific texts there was
enough to read and there he said that by
the time he was finished he would have
the equivalent of several doctorate
degrees doris had taken initial stock of
all the medical supplies available at
the site gauze disinfectant vials upon
vials of medications she had never heard
of and had categorized them all neatly
now she spent her hours mostly sitting
with stella telling her stories about
whatever she felt like her time overseas
her late husband their children
decades-old neighborhood gossip it felt
good to talk no matter what it was about
it felt human they all had their ways of
keeping their grip on their own humanity
it had almost gotten boring holed up in
the facility without the constant threat
of danger pressing in from all sides
boring but peaceful stella could feel
herself starting to nod off her eyelids
sagging her dinner of canned beans
sitting heavy in her stomach next to her
doris had already begun to softly snore
soon sleep would come for her too and
bring with it dreams memory of the life
that was gone forever the world as she
had once known it the dreams were tough
but waking up from them was even tougher
still she had to rest she could only
fight it for so long she could almost
hear her husband's voice when hey stella
you might want to see this brian was
there suddenly his words breaking
through the haze in her mind his tone
was severe and she knew that sleep would
have to wait she followed him down the
hall for a while before he stopped and
turned her attention to a section of a
damaged wall it was rusted and corroded
black and gray with massive cracks in
the solid material it looked like it had
been slowly disintegrated over time by
an incredibly strong acid it was
off-putting to look at giving off the
distinct sense that something bad had
happened but a lot of bad things had
happened in the past month i don't
really understand what i'm looking at
stella said and brian grabbed her by the
shoulders commanding her attention this
wasn't here yesterday hell it wasn't
here a few hours ago he gestured to the
damage it just happened and whatever is
responsible is probably still here a
chill ran down stella's spine it seemed
impossible for this kind of structural
damage to happen over the course of a
few hours she could see twisted steel
rebar drips of melted metal that had
trickled onto the floor as she leaned in
for a closer look she gagged there was
an overpowering stench of rot and decay
it didn't take long for her to spot the
source a thick black mucus covering the
hole in the wall
slick and slimy and giving off the
putrid smell it wasn't like the material
that had made up the flesh creatures
outside it was something else entirely
something she had never seen before she
reached out a hand to touch it but
quickly caught herself whatever this
stuff was it was bad news if it could do
that to a solid wall she didn't even
want to think about what it could do to
flesh and bone what do we do she asked
inspect the area make sure it's safe see
if it's some kind of toxic waste leak or
he didn't finish the thought he didn't
have to they needed to find out if this
damage came from something living
something that could be hiding in the
building with them and waiting for the
chance to strike when they returned to
the main room doris was awake and trina
was there waiting for them they agreed
to split into pairs and search the
facility looking for any additional
damage strange black fluid or signs of
foul play of any kind trina and brian
went one way while doris and stella went
the other each person armed with a
flashlight and a weapon of some kind an
axe a bat a knife stella had found a
loaded pistol when they first arrived
one that she hoped she would never have
to use now she carried it with her just
in case stella and doris walked together
for an hour keeping an eye out for
anything suspicious they didn't find
anything notable really there were some
bits of rust they hadn't seen before an
occasional black puddle pooling on the
floor but nothing like the scene brian
had found as they walked in silence
stella found herself beginning to relax
maybe the worst was over maybe a pipe
had broken somewhere and broken down a
bit of the wall but nothing else would
really come of it then from the other
side of the building there came a
high-pitched scream she knew that voice
immediately trina screaming bloody
murder and brian bellowing something she
grabbed doris by the arm and the two ran
in the direction of the sound as they
got closer they could hear other sounds
in addition to trina and brian's yells
loud cracking like something solid
coming apart bits of rubble falling to
the ground
and the wet dripping sound of something
thick hitting the floor as the two
rounded the corner to see what was
happening to help their friends stella
froze in shock she had seen some
harrowing things since that fateful
sunny day she almost thought she had
become desensitized to horror that there
was nothing left in the world that could
face her but this moment proved her
wrong there was so much to take in and
so little time brian was swinging his
axe wildly at the floor chopping at it
helplessly in an attempt to break it
apart it quickly became obvious why
trina was sinking into the floor not
through a hole into the basement below
but into the floor itself it rippled and
melted around her changing from a solid
surface to a thick pool of black sludge
she flailed and struggled grasping at
the ground around her at brian's arm
anything to yank herself free but she
wouldn't budge she continued to sink no
she wasn't just sinking she was being
pulled stella felt her legs begin to
work again and she rushed to trina's
side grabbing hold of her arms with all
the strength she had all the while trina
screamed in a mix of desperation terror
and pain brian continued his assault on
the ground as if he could cut her free
from the floor and doris moved to help
stella she grabbed a hold of trina's
waist but stopped suddenly there at the
place where her body vanished into the
floor trina was beginning to fall apart
whatever had turned the floor into a
portal whatever had rotted away at the
walls it was taking its toll on her body
too the flesh falling away from the bone
the muscles liquefying and everything
becoming corrupted by that same black
mucus if they pulled any harder trina
would be ripped in two her chest arms
and head on the surface while her legs
stomach and most of her vital organs
were lost there was no way to save her
stella saw it when doris did and the two
shared a long sad look trina was here
with them still struggling for her life
but she was already gone as if it felt
their hopelessness the force pulling on
trina from below then gave a horrifying
yank they were praying to not have to
witness and she was swallowed up by the
ground all that remained was a sticky
black smear a large crack in the floor
and three survivors where there had just
been four none of the remaining three
slept a wink that night brian paced back
and forth holding his axe doris went
over their supplies again looking for
anything that could be used to treat the
effects of the corrosive black fluid and
stella ran over their potential options
again and again they could stay and hope
that the thing that took trina never
came back or they could leave and face
the possibility of succumbing to the sun
or the influence of the creatures that
once were people she recalled dimly an
old adage the devil you know beats the
devil you don't maybe that was true
maybe it would be better to take their
chances with the outside rather than
stay and be hunted but she thought of
her husband and children again watching
them melt onto the grass and she
shuddered there were no good options
here but she couldn't risk going out
like that they would stay whatever had
taken trina there were three of them and
only one of it besides maybe it had
already gotten what it wanted and now it
would move on she didn't know it when
she fell asleep only that when she
eventually woke up she was alone brian
and doris were nowhere to be found she
called out their names as her heart
leaped into her throat for a moment she
feared the very worst but then brian
answered her he had been patrolling
looking for signs of trouble but he was
fine she asked if doris was with him and
he went pale he told stella that doris
had gone to an on-site bathroom to get
cleaned up hours ago before he left she
should have been back by then without
another thought they took off towards
the bathroom and saw their worst fear
realized the door to the room was gone
rotted away and doris was gone with it
she had been taken before she even had
the chance to scream they stood there
taking in the reality of what had
happened with silent shock then a sound
from behind caused them to turn around
it was a raspy hollowed-out sound like
air forced from a dying man's lungs a
dry empty
evil chuckle from an inhuman throat
there they saw the creature that had
stolen their friends from a distance
stella could have confused it for a man
a very old very sick man but still human
as it shuffled closer however that
illusion was shattered its eyes were
black voids its skin gray and putrefied
its mouth a gaping toothless maw of
shriveled black gums and it was laughing
at them like it was enjoying itself
there was the smell again that
overpowering reek of all things foul
stella drew her pistol and fired several
shots she didn't have the best aim
especially not when their hands were
shaking with fear but one of the bullets
found its target and hit the creature in
the cheek it hissed not in pain but a
perverse amusement as the lead tore a
hole through its flesh like wet paper
globs of black blood spattered
everywhere spreading the rot wherever
they landed to her side she heard brian
cry out in pain when she turned he was
clutching his right eye some of the
liquid had hit him there and it was
already taking effect stella's stomach
turned as she saw something white slide
down the side of brian's face his eye
melting out of its socket the skin
around it followed suit softening like
putty and dribbling away from the bloody
muscle underneath brian collapsed to the
floor as the creature continued to
advance on them laughing louder and
louder it knew that bullets couldn't
kill it knew that there was nowhere to
run stella grabbed a hold of brian's
arms prepared to carry her fallen friend
to safety but he stopped her i'm done
for he said quietly if you try to carry
me
you are too she shook her head unwilling
to leave him behind and he touched her
cheek forcing a smile on his decaying
face i
i didn't think i'd make it this far i i
wouldn't have without you so run save
yourself she could hear the resignation
in his voice and knew that he would not
let her save him i'll i'll hold him off
as long as i can brian promised and with
tears in her eyes stella turned and ran
as fast as she could as her feet pounded
the ground blood rushing in her ears she
could hear brian screaming and cursing
at the creature until his voice quickly
faded into a wet gurgle and then silence
stella sat in the center of the room
that she and the others had once shared
clutching her scavenged pistol in her
hands every creak every air and sound
made her jump it could be anywhere come
from anywhere she had escaped from so
much already survived more than anyone
was ever meant to had lost her love her
friends her home she wouldn't lose
herself too she held her breath as she
heard it clear in the darkness drip
drip grip her grip on the weapon
tightened and she readied herself if she
had to go down she might as well go down
swinging the old man whether he was a
man
a monster or death itself wouldn't be
taking her anywhere
not without a fight we'd been so
cautious keeping quiet only moving at
night but sometimes despite all your
best efforts you just get unlucky we
made our way through what we thought was
an abandoned street littered with broken
down cars when those
things had slithered out and ambushed us
kasparov who was always the most
trigger-happy of us panicked and opened
fire with his scavenged submachine gun
on the largest of the creatures big
mistake it didn't slow the monster down
and only seemed to attract more it'd be
blob city before sunrise now but poor
caspar wouldn't make it that long fleshy
tendrils wrapped around his limbs and
pulled him into the terrible mass of one
of the creatures it started reshaping
around him enveloping him as he screamed
until the tide of flesh coursing down
his throat silenced him the whole time
the monster just kept jibbering madness
in a warped voice become one yes
let ourselves spawn and our minds
coagulate in the glorious shimmering
light
we will all be one in daylight pretty
flower
yes
yes
yes
and then there were four me ellen darcy
and jones there have been more of us
once but in this war of attrition we
always seem to be the ones who had to
lose and if we didn't get away from
these monsters quickly then there
wouldn't be any of us left soon enough
we ran
ducking and weaving around the cars as
the blobs got closer there were so many
of them all howling and ranting zealots
were the only cause their melted excuses
for minds could understand anymore
occasionally we fired back hoping to
slow them down a little but it never
worked the guns if anything were a
psychological support mechanism and
something to scare off other survivors
who were even more desperate than us
when it came to the blobs especially the
big ones the only things you could do
were run and hope and hopes in short
supply these days no matter how fast we
ran the blobs kept catching up they
didn't seem to get tired knowing we
couldn't outrun them we ran up to one of
the abandoned cars and crouch behind
them breathing raggedly this whole
stupid mission in hopes of eventually
reaching safety a good night's sleep
behind solid walls and some people who
actually know what the hell is going on
i drew my sidearm out of my pocket even
if i didn't make it out of here i
wouldn't turn into one of those monsters
rolling back the hammer i muttered a
quiet prayer but there's a god out there
he had a hell of a lot to answer for
right now i looked to ellen darcy and
jones and they all had the same idea it
was a pleasure to know them all after
everything that had happened we heard
the blobs getting closer their lunatic
whispers growing in volume and intensity
as they always did before they claimed
one of us i breathed in a sigh ready to
accept my fate knowing what i needed to
do it all seemed to be over until he
appeared i looked up and spotted a
strange man approaching he was dressed
in old-fashioned hessian toga his hair
and beard frosty white i couldn't
identify his age or race but those
factors seem secondary to the fact his
eyes were glowing brilliant white as if
exuding pure energy he raised a hand the
same glowing aura of pure white energy
emanating off of it i'd seen so many
things that terrified me in the past six
months but this this was the first time
i'd experienced something i could call
aw he walked towards us with a stillness
and confidence and said you look like
you could use a hand
where were you when they broke whoever's
left they remember i was in a
supermarket with my wife and two kids
just another normal day i was worrying
about bills taxes and whatever we were
going to have for dinner that night if
the devil exists i'd sell my soul to
that nasty red creep to get those
worries back lucky for us we were in the
back half of the store but entirely by
artificial light the people checking out
their groceries down front right in the
front of the building's huge glass
facade they were the first to go down
all these terrible drowned screams first
the exact kind of shrieks you'd expect
from somebody starting to melt than the
gurgling like a backed up drain as their
mouth and throat melted around the sound
choking it those were the first few
minutes of hell on earth i've never been
the smartest man i was a roofer back
when things made sense never went to
college never been much for reading but
i had intuition and i credit that with
surviving this long my dad was in the
service two tours in nam he always told
me when i was a kid the guys who didn't
make it back they panicked because
that's what the enemy wants you to do
they hope when everything hits the fan
you'll break formation forget the plan
and i'll start scurrying in different
directions like rats just hoping you'll
be the one who finds a crack and gets
out that's when they get you when you
panic you're giving up the birthright of
reason from letting the animal take over
and animals some are easier to kill when
the sun went bad that day plenty of
people in that store started running
they didn't know what they were running
from or where they were running to they
just wanted to put some distance between
themselves and the screaming every man
for himself i'd love to tell you all
those people are dead now but in
actuality they were in for a far worse
fate they ran out of the safety and
cover of the store putting themselves at
the mercy of the light even as they
melted they kept running they were blobs
slithering away not even knowing that
the thing they were running from had
already gotten them it all happened so
fast but i can remember every single
detail you can judge me if you like i
don't care anymore if i could have
spoken reason to those terrified people
that day hand on my heart i would have
but one of man's greatest design flaws
is that god made fear the master of
reason nothing i could have said that
day would have changed anything the only
ones i could hope to save were my family
so that's exactly what i did we grabbed
what we could stayed away from windows
made our way to the nearest supply
closet we were in there for hours we
didn't come out until things were
actually quiet which coincidentally
happened to be night when we stepped
outside the store we saw the carnage
that must have unfolded over the past
few hours windows smashed cars driven
into storefronts and abandoned
slithering blobs of former people on the
ground in the space of a few hours the
world had truly and irrevocably changed
no matter what happened even if we
survived we knew there would never be a
normal as we'd know it before ever again
the same message was playing on every tv
radio and computer a logo i didn't quite
recognize along with an overlay that
read an important message from the scp
foundation it explained in an eternally
looping robotic voice that they were
superseding the control of all world
governments to protect humanity from
this new and terrifying threat in short
the sun had turned against us in some
scenarios survival is a curse in those
early days and weeks you wouldn't
believe the number of times i started to
envy the dead people who had been wiped
off the mortal coil by disease and car
crashes and random acts of violence in
the days before day broke they had no
idea how good they had it little by
little in this terrible new world death
became a kind of luxury because melting
under the fiery gaze of the sun that
wasn't death not even close they seemed
harmless at first tragic pitiful really
the voices on the tv even told us that
to avoid starvation we could eat small
parts of the melted but over time the
situation evolved i don't know when it
started or why but the blobs that had
once been people started coagulating
they joined up started turning into
bigger creatures all with one mind
always screaming and talking madness in
a collage of stolen voices these
monsters existed for one purpose and one
purpose only finding the people who were
still normal and dragging them out into
the light to join them they roamed the
world during the night hunting seeking
and given night was the only time we
could ever safely move this created
problems for all of us we lost so many
to those terrible monsters including my
wife and both my kids see what i mean
about survival sometimes being a curse
especially when you've got people to
miss i wish they were dead all three of
them but i still hear them their voices
added to the chorus of a house-sized
flesh monster but i lived on if you can
call this living i met with others like
kaspar ellen darcy and jones all of them
had lost people you hadn't lived this
long if you hadn't lost people we did
all we could to keep surviving against
the odds we spent our days in basements
and abandoned stores and our nights
dodging the flesh creatures and foraging
for food we eked out each day taking
every breath as it came we didn't help
for anything until one day we heard that
the people at the scp foundation might
know how to reverse all this they needed
all the people and help they could get
at one of their bases around 20 miles
from us it'd only be a couple night's
walk to get there we figured so why not
help out the cause safety in numbers
after all and truth be told
we miss people after days of hiding and
nights of traveling we were ambushed but
you already know about that part we lost
kaspar to one of those monsters and got
cornered behind an abandoned car however
as the blobs got closer and closer that
mysterious stranger with the glowing
eyes appeared he didn't walk like the
rest of us he was bold confident his
back straight as a dancers like he
feared nothing like nothing here could
hurt him suddenly i felt a rumbling
behind me the car was rattling i feared
for a second that the blobs were
crawling over it to get us but when i
turned i saw the opposite was happening
the car was rising off of the ground
free-floating myself and the other
survivors stared in astonishment as the
stranger simply flicked his wrist the
floating car was thrown with tremendous
force at the largest of the advancing
blobs it hit the beast so hard that the
top of it simply splattered off freezing
what was left in place even the other
blobs paused seemingly astonished we all
turned to the stranger still standing
firm stand behind me if you wish to live
he said there was something both
passionate and commanding about his
voice it was impossible to hear him and
not heed his words all of us stood up
and ran behind the stranger as he lifted
both hands debris climbed into the air
cars rocks broken glass the blobs were
beginning to coagulate again but this
time the stranger wasn't going to let
them get the upper hand again with a
slight nod everything he'd raised flew
at the blobs with the force of a machine
gun they were decimated the bigger ones
cut apart the smaller one fleeing to
avoid the onslaught after months of
running from these monsters i don't
think any sight could have been more
satisfying when the creatures were gone
the stranger just gave a quiet sigh he
turned to us and asked if we were okay
the answer was essentially about as much
as we can be he told us that we'd be
safe as long as we stuck with him and
after that display we had every reason
we had every reason to believe him we
followed the stranger down the long dark
road he always walked in the middle
fearless making no attempt to hide when
we asked him his name he told us that he
goes by many names but for the sake of
simplicity we could call him matthew we
thanked matthew for saving us and he
gave a sad sort of smile and told us
that he only wished he could have done
more there was something so strange
about matthew even beyond the fact he
apparently had superpowers i'd never met
the man before and i'd be willing to bet
my right hand on that and yet it felt
like i'd known him my entire life he was
so different and yet so incredibly
familiar we told them we were on our way
to a nearby scp foundation facility
where we were told we'd find safe haven
we asked him if he knew where to find it
matthew told us that in fact he'd lived
there in that very site for decades a
visitor just dropping in he'd had a very
stressful job before and felt like
taking a sabbatical while things ran
themselves for once evidently my help
was more necessary than i imagined
he said occasionally as we walked we'd
see blobs watching us from crevices and
dark alleys on the side of the road they
seemed to watch but for some reason
didn't approach it was the most
remarkable thing don't worry
he told us i'm putting up invisible
shields none of them can approach us as
long as i maintain my focus
of course we'd all heard stories of
remarkable and terrifying things
wandering the wasteland we used to call
planet earth you couldn't run into other
survivors and groups without hearing
whispers about the things lurking out
there some had told of a giant monstrous
reptile that had destroyed an entire
survivor settlement in a mall outside of
nevada others told that one of those scp
sites was haunted people spoke about a
ghostly man who looked like a rotten
corpse who could walk through walls and
drag people to hell but the things
matthew was capable of seemed to be on a
whole other level i asked him what he
was and he told me just a humble
craftsman my son
i enjoy creating though admittedly my
creations seem to have gotten away from
me these days
his evasion was less funny than he
seemed to think it was i pressed on
asking him what exactly he was capable
of he shrugged and answered that he
could do almost anything if he really
put his mind to it i asked so
ultimate power this gave him a chuckle
he shook his head and said let me tell
you a story a man comes upon a maze cut
into a cornfield and decides he wants to
dry his luck
he spends hours getting to the center of
the maze and there he finds the devil
waiting for him the devil says
welcome to my domain your soul is now
forfeit unless you can complete my
challenge and win it back
of course the men agreed the devil said
i can see everything do everything and
be everything
i know every inch of the universe and
can produce anything from thin air
if you want to keep your soul
name one thing i can't do
curious i ask what did the man say
matthew smiled and said good luck
and for the first time in those long
dark months i actually laughed and it
was such a stupid corny dad joke it's a
strange world we live in boy news
matthew continued there is no ultimate
power
some things are denied even to god
especially when he chooses to walk as a
man on the earth he created
we kept walking for hours matthew
assured us that we would get there in
time as the rest of us got even more
anxious about the thought of the rising
sun he said he'd seen so many sunrises
now that he could time them to the
second in the meantime we should enjoy
getting to stretch our legs a little
even now the city could be beautiful at
night when he let us all the way to what
seemed like an abandoned chemical plant
i could feel my heart sink all this time
all this work to find more people to
find safety only to see that this place
was abandoned too matthew smiled and
said that's just what they want you to
think
he snapped his fingers and the ground
around us began to rumble the concrete
shifted seamlessly and an entrance
opened up below heavy bulkheads shifted
revealing a sleek chrome hallway down
into the ground we were astonished
matthew gestured down into the hall as
we descended matthew followed us the
entrance closing behind him i'm just
warning you
he said this may come as a bit of a
shock
we ventured deeper passing through
different automated security checkpoints
as cameras gazed down from above
eventually we found ourselves in what
seemed to be a central chamber it was a
hive of activity people in normal
civilian clothes guards and tactical
gear scientists in lab coats tears
filled my eyes it was the most people
i'd seen in one place in months the man
in the lab coat wearing an extravagant
medallion approached he was making notes
on a clipboard another batch of
survivors good work 343. the man said
matthew smiled and nodded no problem
jack
always happy to help
the man with the medallion jack
presumably turned to me i imagine you've
come a long way he said i nodded
you have no idea
another day another failed attempt at
death if scp-682 had anything even
resembling a sense of humor he might ask
for it to be printed on a motivational
poster and stuck to the side of his
containment chamber where he eternally
melts and regrows at the mercy of high
concentration acid they just
cross-tested him with able again unlike
some of the others he'd been forced to
face that tattooed swordsman seemingly
wasn't intelligent enough to fear he'd
always come back just as stupid and
violent this encounter had left the
heart to destroy reptile at 30 percent
of his previous body mass bloody and
bashed he'd survived the encounter he
always survived they brought what was
left of him back to his cell in a
forklift a blasted forklift how could it
even be more humiliating as his eyes
started to grow back in his head he
could swear he even saw one of the
technicians laughing at him his name tag
read agent nigel kelly noted 682 would
specifically hunt down and kill him the
next time he breached of course every
single day he plotted revenge against
the human race along with everything
else but the sum they owed in pain blood
and despair could never be repaid in
full after all every single one of them
except dr bright could only really die
once they'd brought 682 to the precipice
a thousand times only for his own body
to cheat him and deprive him of the
sweet release of death and if the
foundation had their way it would be
done a thousand times more and they
wouldn't even stop there 632 couldn't
even imagine the number of containment
breaches it would take to deal a blow
even comparable to the one he had faced
all he could do was dream dream of a
reckoning that would turn the tables
something that would plunge humanity
into the state of constant pain and
terror that had been all he'd ever known
since these fumbling sadists and white
coats had locked him up here what a
beautiful day that would be little did
scp-682 know that very day was about to
break miles and miles away from the
facility where scp-682 was kept after
all orders from the o5 council have hard
mandates on the minimum distances
between people and a site holding a
monster as volatile as 682 parents
watched their children laughing and
frolicking in an idyllic playground some
squealed with glee as they descended the
slide some of the more ambitious little
tykes tried to go over the bar on the
swings others waited in line for some
delicious soft serve at a parked ice
cream truck one mother brought an ice
cream cone and walked over to a nearby
bench where she began to enjoy her
delicious frozen treat it was a
remarkably hot day out and a little ice
cream was the perfect addition to her
relaxation while her kids were occupied
you could see the distant air wobbling
in the heat already her ice cream was
starting to melt white rivulets
dribbling down the sides of the cone and
onto her hands suddenly almost
imperceptibly the quality of the light
shifted the kind of thing you'd dismiss
as a trick of the eyes and forget just
as quickly were it not for the
catastrophic effects that were about to
unfold as the woman leaned forward to
lick her melting ice cream something
dripped onto her skirt but as she looked
down she slowly realized that what
dripped onto her wasn't the pure white
of her ice cream it was the same exact
tone as her skin she felt a terrible
burning sensation all through her body
the most horrible debilitating pain
she'd ever experienced like every cell
in her body was screaming and trying to
make a break for it she turned to the
other parents sitting near the
playground they were screaming too each
collapsed to the ground with agonizing
slowness different parts of their body
falling at different speeds as they
transition through states of matter when
they hit the ground they were taking on
a liquid state screaming worthless
boneless blobs the woman even saw her
own arm wilting like a time lapse video
of a dying flower she dripped and
sluiced through the cracks in the bench
until nothing recognizably human was
left only a soggy ice cream cone sitting
uneaten in an instant billions of
screams rang out over planet earth day
had broken things would never ever be
the same again as almost half of
humanity instantaneously
took on a liquid state needless to say
with the most dangerous and far-reaching
anomalous incident in human history
suddenly breaking out without any kind
of warning the scp foundation was
incredibly busy this would take some
unprecedented action the members of the
o5 council who weren't melted during the
initial blast convened over secure video
link while sequestering themselves
underground and what amounted to
multiple human lifetimes of some of the
most high pressure choices imaginable
they made the most difficult decision
since the very beginning of the scp
foundation in the service of all mankind
they would now break the masquerade the
scp foundation would at long last step
out of the shadows to save the rest of
humanity from the tyranny of the light
broadcasts went out all over the globe
every tv screen every live stream every
radio broadcast was commandeered they
gave instructions based on the scattered
intel they had for some reason the sun
had turned against them exposure would
lead any biological creatures melting
away into sentient piles of
flesh-colored sludge people would remain
indoors and away from any light sources
all windows must remain covered travel
only at night and even then heavily
covered with protective gear there can
only be one objective for whoever is
left make your way to the nearest scp
foundation containment facility and seek
refuge inside if anyone could figure out
the answer to this terrifying
existential riddle it would be the scp
foundation anyone who is exposed should
be considered lost while as always the
scp foundation did all they could to
project a sense of control over the
situation on the inside it was
pandemonium somehow despite everything
this event had taken all of them by
surprise how could anyone have predicted
that the cradle of our solar system's
delicate living balance would suddenly
become a meat grinder a huge number of
foundation operatives were wiped out in
the initial exposure global
communication infrastructure had been
devastated it was pure chaos and to
scp-682
as another evil tactician once put it
chaos was a ladder from the inside of
his acid tank 6av2 could sense the fear
and pain suddenly exuding from his
surrounding environment it was greater
than ever before what was happening out
there this was no average containment
breach something was really really
happening out there 682 began to adapt
and finally attune its hearing until
could pick up the chatter from outside
uh maybe we can convert some of the
d-class barracks into serviceable
bunkers for the refugees it's not like
we're prepared for this kind of capacity
oh god oh god we've lost sight seven
site 10 site 23 site 40 site 52 ah death
toll looks to be in the billions well we
don't know if they're dead technically
but they're sure as hell not human
anymore this is the big one this is it
xk class even 2 000 is unaccounted for
is all five crazy that they think we're
fighting the freaking sun needless to
say 682's curiosity was peaked anything
that could light a fire under the
foundation like this was something he
could enjoy and with his impressively
strategic intellect he intuited that a
time of great strife for the foundation
would be the perfect time to breach
containment because whenever there's
violence fear and chaos on a mass scale
scp-682 will be there causing it 682
began adapting his pores and endocrine
system to begin releasing a powerful
alkaline substance little by little the
alkaline neutralized the acids
surrounding him turning it into little
more than plain water he then converted
his internal systems to have extreme
endothermic rather than exothermic
properties causing his surrounding
temperature to drop rapidly until all
the water in the tank completely froze
around him the ice expanded beyond the
limit of the containment unit busting
the rivets of the metal frame and
shattering the reinforced glass with his
goal achieved 682 raised his internal
temperatures to incredible highs melting
the ice around him once again he was
free and ready for some good
old-fashioned carnage and mayhem perhaps
he could get a better handle on this
strange new situation too it was all
rather exciting just a girl with goals
huh scp foundation personnel were
already running around like ants trying
desperately to avoid the caustic laser
beam of the magnifying glass you can
only imagine how much worse it made
matters when 682 suddenly burst through
the wall kool-aid man's style he began
to ruthlessly massacre everyone around
him just one of those days you know the
typical order during a 682 containment
breach is to dispatch all available
units to get him back under control the
issue with this particular containment
breach was that given the human
population was very rapidly being melted
and they were the only ones who could
potentially save the rest they didn't
really have any available units to
pursue and recontain 682 for once he
really wasn't a priority and that meant
terrible things for whoever he ran into
682 slaughtered his way through any
researchers or guards who dared to get
in his way disgusting creatures really
better off dead he clawed and bit and
tore and crushed with almost childlike
bleed leaving great piles of bodies in
his wake all the while he was pondering
the things he heard those foundation
drones saying something about the sun
and an xk class scenario
interesting 682 also observed that any
apertures that could potentially allow
light into the facility had also been
shuttered perhaps they weren't
overreacting this time like they always
did with him maybe they were dealing
with some kind of phenomenon that would
now cast this wretched world and those
who lived in it into the void wouldn't
that be a fitting karmic fate for them
all still 682's bloodlust didn't
outweigh his logic he needed to know
more about the situation before
proceeding and in this
maybe he could kill two foundation birds
with one stone elsewhere in the building
alarms blared the air was suffused with
panicked voices and frequent screams
nobody knew what was going on not really
they'd only gotten details here and
there and the details they'd received
were terrifying all their families and
loved ones outside probably gone so many
of the people in so much of the world
they'd been fighting for risking it all
for had disappeared in an instant
carried to hell on a ray of sunshine why
were they still here was this horror not
truly uncontainable these questions were
swimming through the mind of agent nigel
kelly as he stood alone in his office
almost catatonic it had his friends and
family on the outside all likely reduced
to those horrible fleshy blobs he was
alone in the world risking his life for
nothing how could this get any worse his
mind kept repeating that question again
and again and again and the universe
gave him an answer in the form of a deep
reptilian voice saying
into his ear from behind he turned with
a shriek to see the terrible eyes of 682
staring into his own before he could try
to flee or reach for a weapon that he
knew would only mildly annoy the already
furious beast 682 reached out with a
massive clawed hand and grabbed him by
the torso lifting him up into the air
the creature was gripping so tight that
he could feel his ribs starting to crack
the monster hissed am i funny
do i see
the time to tell
jokes do you feel
like laughing now
agent kelly begged and pleaded for his
life fighting for his next breath from
the crushing squeeze of the creature's
terrible hand 682 roared at him to be
silent and ordered him to tell him
everything he knew about the situation
going on outside if the information was
useful 682 might show his thought to be
non-existent magnanimous side and let
agent kelly live of course agent kelly
didn't fancy his chances but what other
choice did he have he told 682 that the
higher-ups were calling this
scp-001 when day breaks the sun had gone
rogue somehow and being in contact with
any kind of sunlight would now cause
people to instantaneously melt into
horrifying living sludge and it wasn't
just people the condition also affected
anomalies and interestingly it appeared
to negate all previous anomalous effects
so 682's adaptational ability may not
even save it if it was exposed he told
682 everything he knew are you are you
gonna let me live agent kelly asked
struggling to breathe 682's terrible maw
twisted into what might have been a
smile
he said with unsettling joy
[Music]
a terrible scream emanated from the
agent's office if one good thing could
be said for what happened to agent kelly
that day at least he didn't live long
enough to see the ravages of the
terrible sun first hand 682 began to
formulate a plan he took agent kelly's
wristwatch and integrated it into his
body so he'd have a permanent internal
clock it was the middle of summer so the
sun would have reliably set at 9 9pm and
would likely begin its rise around 5am
it would be relatively easy to avoid the
sun all things considered for lack of a
more eloquent way to put it when it
comes to adapting to new threats
scp-682 is simply built different after
slaughtering a few other members of scp
foundation staff for the road hey it's
not like anyone was fit to stop him 682
began enacting the new phase of his plan
his body grew a thick smooth carapace
and his front set of limbs began to grow
his muscles bulging and his claws
growing the tips turning into sharp flat
scoops with sudden and tremendous force
682 began boring his way into the ground
tunneling clawing through concrete and
dirt with absolute ease normally the scp
foundation would have deployed high-tech
seismic sensors and the kind of tunnel
boring machines that elon musk could
only dream of to intercept and recapture
him but during the endless horrors of
the breaking day he had carte blanche to
escape and live it up in the ruins of
this rapidly dying world eventually 682
had bored his way into a roomy sewer
pipe the perfect place to wait out a few
hours up above so many millions screamed
either in fear or in agony there had
been some new developments that the scp
foundation had been yet to account for
while they knew that those melted by the
rogue son were technically alive and
trapped in a permanent state of
suffering what the foundation didn't
know was that these former humans were
incredibly dangerous in their own right
the sun hadn't just irreparably warped
their bodies it had also irreparably
warped their minds it has enslaved them
made them zealots acolytes they
developed the instinct to coagulate into
giant flushing masses driven by the
single-minded purpose of finding victims
and dragging them into the light where
they too could be converted into these
terrible fleshy creatures and add to the
masses they were the rogue's sons boots
on the ground metaphorically speaking
and now they were the foundation's
greatest challenge in getting a handle
on this situation again before it was
just encouraging people to avoid the sun
now the sun was actively trying to
increase its exposure but 682 who was
having a relaxing evening not being
melted for once down in the sewers
couldn't care less he was having the
most calming few hours he'd had in years
he waited checking the time making sure
that it would be dark before he began
tunneling back up to the surface world
he surfaced in the middle of the city
miles away from the foundation facility
he'd spent so many decades being
tortured in he tasted the cool night air
and observed the desolation that had
been rocked all around him buildings
were on fire cars were crashed and
overturned the ground was cracked
garbled scp foundation public service
announcements played to nobody in the
broken display windows of electronics
stores giant wads of human flesh roamed
slithering around searching for new
victims one noticed 682 and began to
approach him jibbering madly in a chorus
of strange voices the hard to destroy
reptile wasted no time in attacking it
tore apart most of the hideous blob and
began hungrily devouring the chunks the
form may have been different but it
still tasted like human flesh and
scp-682
savored every bite it would be
so simple these blobs of idiotic flesh
were so easy to kill
and there would be so many terrified
humans in this devastated world hiding
away in dark places holding out the hope
that maybe they could reach the safety
of a foundation facility 682 chuckled at
the very thought foolish hope would
drown in an endless well of black
caustic despair
he would find them he would rest
underground in the day and then hunt
them in the dark they would all die
screaming
bloodying his claws and fangs
nothing and nobody would stop him he
looked out over the strange new world
and laughed a little louder
[Music]
it was just delightful
lewis jackson sat with all his fellow
students in the dingy underground
lecture hall listening to a rickety old
professor with a voice like chloroform
rattling off dry facts about economics
above him a projector older than any of
the students in the room covered the
wall in a poorly designed powerpoint
presentation limping from slide to slide
it was 9 am on a thoroughly unremarkable
monday half the class was hung over the
other was just terminally bored lewis
hoped none of this would come up on the
final because this morning he had no
intention of listening instead he was
typing out a message under the desk with
a big stupid grin on his face professor
harbison is going off about the free
market again
save me send the messages recipient
jenny park started typing lewis's crush
on jenny was the college's worst kept
secret ever since they met during o week
he'd been infatuated with her they
shared a few classes but little by
little they started hanging out more in
their free time study sessions grabbing
lunch together going to the movies
they'd become fast friends but lewis was
hoping they could be something more and
he hoped deep down jenny was thinking
the same thing he received a text we can
hang out in the quad after if it makes
him easier to endure we'll grab burgers
my treat with a winking emoji lewis felt
like a dork to admit it even to himself
but this message made his heart race
they were doing winking emojis now maybe
today wouldn't be such a drag after all
any day that he got to hang out with
jenny couldn't be all that bad
all this news was so exciting to him he
didn't notice that something strange was
sweeping over the lecture hall while the
professor droned on even the most
studious members of the class were
suddenly checking their phones faces a
light with expressions of confusion then
concern then worry something was
happening something big professor
harbison fell silent as a new sound rose
to prominence muffled at first but
getting rapidly louder just outside the
lecture hall it was screaming terrible
screams of fear and pain people started
to rise out of their seats what was
going on out there nobody had heard
gunshots or an explosion the ground
wasn't rumbling under their feet and if
a hurricane or tornado was tearing its
way across the campus they would have
heard it suddenly the main doors to the
lecture hall burst open and a terrified
student rushed through lewis recognized
him it was tommy landsdale a history
major that lewis had hung out with a few
times at campus parties he was a chill
guy the kind of person who took
everything on the chin and let life's
troubles just roll off his back that's
why it was so strange to see his whole
body shaking and his face a red mess of
tears
he can't go out there he screamed
there's something wrong with the light
concern was starting to give way to
panic tommy turned and shoved the bolt
into place on the door eliminating the
potential exit the only other way out
was a fire escape down by the stage his
heavy breathing and choked sobs weren't
doing much to calm anyone down lewis
checked his phone again jenny was still
typing tommy kept repeating something's
wrong with the light something's wrong
with the light something's wrong with
the light the other students were
starting to approach him all with a
sense of guarded caution given they
still didn't understand the situation
well enough to know for sure that tommy
wasn't the dangerous one here college
could be an extremely stressful place it
definitely wasn't unheard of for people
to snap under the pressure and do
something they wouldn't normally do
what what's going on man lewis said
walking briskly up to tommy worried
about jenny's safety if something really
was happening out there tommy raised
both hands in a gesture that seemed
halfway between pleading and a threat
shaking his head frantically stay back
dude
you don't want to go out there something
terrible is happening professor harbison
approached adjusting his glasses and
sneering he didn't take kindly to
someone interrupting his lecture with
these ridiculous theatrics an institute
of learning was no place for this kind
of troublemaker i demand you leave this
instant young man harbison said if you
don't stop this foolish behavior i'll
have you written up tommy didn't budge
he just shook his head emphatically i'm
not going anywhere he said if you go out
there you're gonna die i'm not letting
anyone leave this damn building before
anyone could protest this unwilling
confinement a terrible sound started to
come from outside not screaming this
time just a voice a warped pained voice
that seemed almost to droop as it spoke
like a voice recorded on an old
reel-to-reel tape recorder that's
starting to degrade
it slurred please
let me in
i
feel so sick
there was a terrible slopping noise like
a thick viscous liquid sluicing closer
tommy looked down and screamed
flesh-colored slime was slithering in
underneath the door and dripping over
the top step of the gangway tommy
stepped back along with everyone else it
looked revolting and smelled even worse
like a mixture of rotten meat and
burning hair that terrible drooping
voice was still somehow emanating from
the slime
please please help me something went
wrong
naturally the other students began to
scream and run whatever that monster was
they needed to get away from it quickly
only lewis seemed to be rooted in place
the terror and impossibility of it all
just paralyzing him he could only watch
as the flesh-colored blob creature
seeped in under the door everything else
including professor harbison who was
moving faster than he had in years made
a mad dash for the fire exit down by the
stage tommy screamed for them to stay
inside but it was already too late
people panicked and piled on top of each
other to get out but the second they did
the worst of the screaming started the
most awful agonized whales you've ever
heard that tapered off in that same
drooping gurgle as the blob slithered in
underneath the door it was louis's
natural instinct to run down and help
somehow but instead he felt tommy's
white knuckle grip on his shoulder
i'm sorry tommy said through the sobs
it's too late for them
there's nothing you can do man
we just need to stay inside at that
moment lewis received a text message
from jenny it read louis if you're still
okay you need to read this and you need
to believe me something terrible has
happened so many people are dead or at
least i think they're dead a lot of them
are still screaming i think it has
something to do with the sun stay out of
the light i'm in administration building
c i'm safe for now but i'm hiding don't
come looking for me until nightfall
please let me know if you're okay you
can't trust the sun lewis felt a wave of
relief and terror wash over him jenny
was okay and that was great news but it
seemed like this nightmare whatever the
hell it was was affecting everyone out
there it was a force melting people down
and turning them into monsters the
screams from outside the door were
getting worse all those people who had
been well people so recently were
something entirely different now and
they were in terrible terrible pain
lewis and tommy ran down to the fire
escape next to the stage and forced it
shut trying not to look at the tide of
liquid flesh that was rolling in the
apparently hostile sun outside they were
lost now tommy and lewis didn't want
them coming back in lewis breathed a
rattling sigh and hammered out a reply
to jenny i'm safe in a lecture hall with
tommy lansdale we'll come to you as soon
as we can don't worry it's all gonna be
okay lewis shoved his phone back into
his pocket now isn't the time to keep
checking he asked tommy what he knew how
he had survived
whatever all this was having some kind
of knowledge about what they were
dealing with might have given them a
better chance of surviving tommy had
just finished up a seminar in a nearby
classroom and was headed over to the
canteen to grab a reuben while preparing
for his next class he was lucky enough
to be under a covered walkway bathed in
the early morning shade when something
about the sun changed it was hard to
even describe a certain shift in the
quality of the light a kind of
shimmer almost it didn't affect him but
the people in the courtyard a few feet
away he was shuddering as he told the
next part of the story he swallowed hard
over a lump in his throat staring off
into the distance with a haunted look as
the memories played over his mind tommy
described the people in the courtyard
the ones out of the shade who were first
exposed they just started screaming and
falling apart losing form
melting becoming awful piles of
shapeless slop on the ground it was
instantaneous and all it seemed to take
was a fraction of a second of sun
exposure for the whole process to take
effect nothing was worth the risk of
exposure to something like that
nothing but lewis disagreed there was
one thing worth risking his life or the
integrity of his body for
jenny they had to get to administration
building c as quickly as possible and
not just because of the new threat
raging outside but because building c
already had a certain
reputation rumor had it that a number of
people had gone missing in that building
back in the 1970s
since then people had experienced
strange inexplicable things odd chills
strange noises creeping feelings of doom
in certain areas in short it was the
last place lewis wanted jenny to be
trapped but neither he nor tommy could
help until night fell seeing as they
wouldn't be great rescuers in a
semi-liquid state they waited for 10
torturous hours in that lecture hall as
day turned to night outside in that time
they heard so many terrible bubbling
screams out there pain trying to escape
a slimy prison it was enough to drive
you mad with fear both checked the news
and their twitter feeds on their phones
hoping to find out if there was any more
information on what was happening out
there it seemed the worst had come to
pass this insane phenomenon was
unfolding everywhere people across the
world were suffering under the
transforming rays of the terrible new
sun some group called the scp foundation
was releasing information about it
telling people to come towards their
buildings at night for safety lewis
committed this fact to memory when
they'd collected jenny they'd head
straight to one of these buildings
hopefully someone out there could tell
them what the hell was going on here
someone out there had to have answers
about all of this when it got dark
outside lewis felt his phone buzz in his
pocket as he received another text from
jenny this time it was lewis i'm scared
please come quickly i'm downstairs and
with that lewis knew it was time to
leave he and tommy steeled themselves
and when they were sure it was dark out
they ventured forth from the lecture
hall and on to the quad there they saw
the aftermath of the horrors that the
sun had wrought the grass was covered in
more huge flesh-colored blobs slithering
across the grass like mutant slugs just
the sight of them made lewis and tommy
feel nauseous but they didn't have time
to stop and take a breather if jenny was
in trouble they needed to get to
building c fast it looked even more
frightening at night it occurred to both
lewis and tommy at that moment that
neither of them had ever actually been
inside this building before and what
seemed like the end of the world was
certainly an interesting time to start
lewis and tommy entered the building and
turned on the lights in the lobby they
heard a voice at first oddly toneless
and robotic but soon realized it was a
video playing on loop on the computer at
the unmanned reception desk it was
another message from the scp foundation
this is a public service announcement
from the scp foundation we are
commandeering all broadcast channels and
frequencies to deliver a vital message
avoid sunlight at all costs cover your
bodies thoroughly and follow the
instructions on the screen to reach the
nearest operational scp foundation
containment site neither like the sound
of the phrase containment site but
they'd worry about the semantics later
jenny had said she'd been hiding
downstairs and there was no sign of her
here on the first floor so it stood to
reason she was on some kind of basement
level strange it seemed like all the
doors here led up except one a door that
looked like until very recently it had
been bolted to the wall
well
lewis said trying to mask his fear i
guess it's now or never tommy opened his
mouth to answer but before a single word
could pass his lips a huge fleshy
tendril shot through the front door of
the building and wrapped around his
throat he managed only a choked gasp as
it dragged him back towards the door on
the other side of the threshold a
mountain of flesh eagerly waited a
gibbering nightmare of half-formed faces
screamed and wailed in the terrible
fleshy form it happened so quickly that
lewis couldn't even hope to save him he
was gone subsumed by the blob his face
disappearing into the flesh before lewis
could even scream but there was no time
to stop and process the shock another
several tendrils were already reaching
for him he could practically see it
happening in slow motion pulsing
grasping for him perhaps it was only his
will to see jenny again that gave him
the strength to do so but he dodged the
tendrils by a fraction of an inch and
dove towards the door the same door he
assumed jenny had escaped in two hours
earlier he threw open the door and
disappeared behind it slamming it in
place and holding it fast he could feel
the tendrils smashing up against it
hammering away lewis heard all those
terrible deranged voices screaming for
him on the other side he was holding it
for a solid 10 minutes before the
creature finally gave up and slithered
away the second the silence fell lewis's
phone buzzed in his pocket again he
fished it out and saw another message
from jenny it read please come afraid so
dark here so dark here so dark here so
dark here and it was at that moment that
lewis began to take in his new
surroundings he was standing in a
stairwell one that seemed much older and
more dilapidated than even the rest of
the building but most notable of all was
the fact that he had never ever seen a
place so dark impossibly dark not dark
as in the absence of light but dark as
in an almost physical presence
choking out the light even with his
phone on full power the light didn't
penetrate much of the black was jenny
all the way down here lewis was afraid
he could only imagine how jenny was
feeling down there in the depths he took
a deep breath and started descending
down into the darkness using his phone
camera to light with little of the way
was possible the deeper he got the more
he started to feel a strange intangible
dread beginning to creep in like an
invisible hand compressing his chest as
he got deeper he noticed a sound quiet
weeping an unmistakably female voice
somewhere down below it sounded too
young to be jenny but then again lewis
had never actually heard her cry before
whatever the case he needed to get down
there and remedy the situation he forged
on further and further into the dark
even as his terrible sense of dread
increased he couldn't help but notice
that no matter how far down he went it
always sounded like the crying was the
same distance away it unnerved him but
jenny had to be down there she had to be
and even if he gave up on her it's not
like he could just go back up and leave
there were monsters out there like the
monster that had gotten tommy even down
here in the darkness he was safer than
up there or at least that's what he
thought he felt something strange under
his foot and looked down it was an old
piece of torn up orange fabric with d
9884 written on it the phone buzzed
again a new message from jenny this time
it read i can see you and you see me
lewis looked around he couldn't see
anything he tried desperately calling
jenny again he yelled her name until his
voice went hoarse no reply just that
same soft weeping so far below maybe she
was on the flight below him she must
have been close he doubled his speed
vaulting down the stairs to the next
level when he noticed something on the
ground a smartphone one that over so
many study dates lunches and outings to
the movies he learned to recognize it
was jenny's he picked it up studying it
only to see that it was dead the screen
cracked in the battery lifeless his own
phone gave another buzz a text from
jenny it read look down and against all
rational thought that's exactly what he
did there was something at the bottom of
the stairs a strange pale face somehow
illuminated in the darkness at first he
thought it could have been her and ran
towards it by the time he realized he
was wrong and he was staring into the
blank eyes of a face without a mouth
inches from his own face it was already
too late lewis let out a scream there
was nobody there to hear him but on the
bright side at least he never would see
that sunlight again sun's gone bad
people and animals are melting
everywhere the world is coming to an end
and there's nothing i could do about it
will i be able to find food while i'll
be able to defeat or avoid the horrific
flesh monsters all around me or the
desperate and hungry survivors left in
this terrible new world keep watching
and find out can i survive 100 days in
scp-001 when day breaks hey folks it's
your boy kyle you probably know me more
for gaming videos than post-apocalyptic
vlogs but hey i'm a versatile guy and i
think i might go insane from the fear if
i don't talk to somebody about all this
craziness if you're live and seeing this
right now well congratulations you're
probably doing a lot better than most
people here if you call them people now
but if you're seeing this a few years in
the future like i don't know you woke up
from a 10-year coma like rick from the
walking dead and you're wondering what
the hell happened to planet earth this
video is probably going to answer a lot
of your questions first things first
whatever you do you've got to stay away
from the sun it touches you for even a
second you're dead or worse welcome to
day one of the end of the world for all
of you who are still in a solid state of
matter you're probably wondering how i'm
still alive too chances are it's for the
exact same reason you are sheer dumb
luck i was down here my gaming basement
when day broke just level grinding when
my tv got taken over by those scp
foundation people telling us that the
sun's gone evil for whatever reason and
now we've all got to stay inside hell if
i was up there making myself a sandwich
or grabbing another can of mountain dew
i'd be a freaking puddle right now it's
funny my mom always told me spending all
day indoors was bad for me
i'll have to mention that to her if
she's alive point is the world has gone
to hell in a hand basket and now i've
got only one objective survive i'm going
to see if i can survive the horrifying
post-apocalyptic world of when day
breaks for this first day i'm just gonna
hunker down i kinda hope this is just a
dream day two all right i'm up and at
him baby sadly i can now report that
this isn't a dream this really is our
horrible new reality it's the sun's
world and we're just living in it i've
been spending the last several hours
just waiting for nightfall outside
against all odds the internet and the
power grid haven't gone down yet guess
what's ever wrong with the sun only
affects people and animals not objects
thank heaven for small mercies right
people on twitter have been live posting
their situations out there sharing
advice on how we might all be able to
stay out of the sun and survive this
whole crazy thing and hey unless they're
dead or full of hot air maybe those scp
foundation people know something about
what's going on here if we really can
get to their buildings maybe we can
figure out how to reverse all this mess
maybe for now i'm just gonna focus on
staying alive hopefully night hit soon i
really need to use the bathroom oh boy
it's day three and new issues are
starting to pop up i've been heading
upstairs to go to the bathroom but while
i don't want to be crude i'm running low
on toilet paper and it's um starting to
become a problem i ran out of my last
roll a few days ago and now i'm starting
to go to my bookshelves i have a few
newspapers left that i tore up and used
for toilet paper first
they weren't exactly comfortable but hey
you need to make do but without toilet
paper and without newspapers i need to
figure out what my favorite and least
favorite books are i'm starting with the
prefaces of all the books seeing as i
don't generally need to reread them you
know they're expendable you know a lot
of these books i haven't read since i
was like 15. so maybe those will be the
ones i can't make up my mind on whether
i'm gonna use the harry potter books or
the percy jackson and the olympian books
first uh let me know what you think in
the comments i guess i need to go to the
bathroom day four and now i'm trying to
figure out how to pass the time as you
already know i'm an avowed lifelong
gamer so while the electricity and the
internet still work i'm gonna keep
gaming to pass the time and keep my all
too precious sanity i still have no
intention of going out there even at
night but it's left me feeling kind of
stir crazy i want to walk around the
city again i want to go for a drive and
feel the breeze in my hair but seeing as
i can't do that without experiencing a
truly horrifying transformation i've
been spending a lot of time on gta 5
online guess we'll never get gta 6 now
what a bummer still these last few days
it's felt more like los santos has been
my home than where i actually live there
were even a few other people on the
server i don't know about you but i take
some comfort in that hey folks i'm back
thankfully welcome to day five we've
still got electricity thankfully hence
why you can still see this i haven't
heard anything from my family and i
don't want to assume the worst but yeah
it's probably just best not to think
about it i've been heading up and
downstairs to grab more food at night
you're probably wondering but kyle why
don't you bring it all downstairs to
save going up all together which i'd say
i don't have a fridge downstairs smart
ass but i'm starting to realize
food is going to be a real issue here
it's kind of stupid now that i think
about it and all the zombie movies and
tv shows i used to watch it was all
bullets and baseball bats killing your
way through all those undead freaks and
worrying about the rest later yes they
don't want you to think about how you're
only gonna ever be a couple weeks away
from starvation kind of ruins the badass
post-apocalyptic power fantasy i only
have a couple days worth of food left
here and after that i'm gonna need to go
out and search for more or i'm gonna
need to relocate i don't feel
comfortable here anymore you know early
on i thought when you got exposed to the
sunlight it just killed you but no it's
worse you keep living you're just
changed into one of those
things these last few days i've looked
out the windows when i've come up at
night for food i i see them sometimes
slithering in the yard or down the
street these things that used to be
people i wonder if they're people that i
knew once before all this and i tried to
shove the thought out of my mind
freaking myself out about all this
doesn't help i know that much just keep
thinking about how they move this like
weird kind of purpose like they're
searching for something but what could
they be searching for i'm just gonna go
and get more food we'll speak again soon
stay safe whoever you are
welcome to day six it's night time now
and i'm heading out for the first time i
keep seeing these weird slimy creatures
everywhere and they make me kind of sick
to look at them but i try my best to
just keep moving i'm on a mission
tonight i'm going to go to the local
supermarket and check to see if there's
still food there while also grabbing
myself a quick snack i'm going to keep
this one brief i don't want to do a full
shopping spree tonight it's already too
late just need to know the food is there
i decided earlier in the night if i
survive this thing and the getting is
good at the bargain mart i'll make my
way back tomorrow for something a little
more you know substantial after all the
fewer trips i make out the safer i'm
likely to be by the time i made it to
the supermarket though while i was
practically a nervous wreck from the
fear of turning into one of those things
i made an amazing discovery while the
windows were broken and the floor was a
mess most of the food was still there
day seven or should i say night seven
galvanized by my success from the
previous days i decided to come back to
the supermarket with a shopping cart i
wanted to get enough food for at least a
week so i wouldn't need to come back out
again hey maybe i'm not so bad at this
whole apocalypse thing after all i
grabbed plenty of canned food from the
supermarket most of the perishables had
already gone moldy by the time i showed
up so fresh fruit was out of the
question suddenly i started getting
scared about the thought of scurvy but
pushed it quickly from my mind i'd
crossed that bridge when i got to it hey
hey it's day eight and i'm still kicking
that's gotta count for something right i
started taking more trips out at night
time just to stretch my legs and keep
the blood flowing when the slithering
things that were once people pass me i
just make myself scarce and hide in the
shadows you know i hear them muttering
sometimes and like this melted voice or
voices it's unsettling but it's amazing
what you'll get used to in just over a
week it's eerie to see all these streets
without people in them i know that i
should probably just stay inside but i i
really can't i don't know if this will
ever just stop and if it doesn't i i
don't want to spend my last days cooped
up in my own basement
day nine you know there are some
benefits to being in the post-apocalypse
to ever so slightly offset all the
utterly crushing downsides while during
the day we're all prisoners of the sun
in our own homes at night we can do
whatever the hell we want i took a
baseball bat that i keep in my closet
and went to the local furniture store i
smashed up every single vase and all the
windows like one of those rage rooms
because nobody could stop me then
afterwards i went straight to the local
computer and gaming store and took all
the alienware tech i could physically
carry you know there's no value in money
anymore if you want something you can
just go and take it every cloud has a
silver lining day 10 more gta 5 today i
decided to get on my headset and speak
to a few others who were still around
and on the servers you know it was so
nice to speak to other human beings for
once they came from all over the world
and we're dealing with the same evil sun
insanity as me you have no idea how
incredibly valuable it is to find people
to talk to in a time like this the other
players had plenty of theories as to why
all this had happened some thought it
was some kind of mutant solar flare
they'd remembered reading about on some
conspiracy form back in the day others
speculated it was the result of some
weapon created by the us or russian or
chinese military that had gone wrong one
person said that maybe it was a
punishment from god
maybe on some level we all deserved it
you know things got pretty quiet after
that day 11. i've been having the most
terrible nightmares lately it's probably
just a product of all the stress i've
been under lately but in the nightmares
i'm running down a dark street being
chased by those flesh creatures i'm
moving fast but they're moving way
faster they're whispering to me but i
can't make out anything they're saying
this morning which is to say evening i
woke up screaming and drenched in sweat
i can't really explain why but i feel
like something terrible is gonna happen
soon okay okay i'm alive that's enough
isn't it and if you're watching this i
assume you're live too congratulations
welcome to the nightmare space between
day 11 and day 27. sorry that i haven't
been in contact for so long as you can
see i'm not at home anymore you couldn't
pay me to go back there
not that money is worth anything anymore
a lot's happened since i last made one
of these and i wish i could tell you any
of it was good hell i wish i could
forget it all but the things i've seen
and heard i don't think they're ever
gonna leave my head no matter what i do
i thought about making another entry now
and then but i always found a reason to
put it off it's remarkable how your
other priorities fall away when you're
just thinking about where your next meal
is coming from it just kind of puts
everything into perspective of course
during my travels i saw more of those
freaks slithering around sorry sorry i i
know i shouldn't call them that it's
kind of a coping mechanism you know it
all gets a lot harder when you have to
think of them as ex-people that's
another thing all these goofy zombie
shows got wrong it's a lot harder to
separate what they were from what they
are now especially when you know these
were your friends your neighbors your
well i can't avoid talking about it
forever can i i stuffed my backpack with
whatever i could grab and left my home
two nights ago it wasn't just because i
was going stir crazy back there though i
admit that didn't exactly help it was
what happened there i just came back
from a food run put most of it in the
fridge then retired back down into the
basement to enjoy a late night snack and
do a little gaming to keep myself sane
i've been doing everything i could to
reverse my circadian rhythms and sleep
during the day just so i could be fully
operational during the 12-hour period
that going outside wouldn't melt me but
just like all those stories they told us
when we were kids there are monsters out
there at night and they are looking for
us when i first heard the sound i was i
wondered if it was something in game or
maybe dripping from a leaky pipe but no
it was too close to be fake and too
viscous to be watered that's when i
looked at the door and saw this awful
pink slime slithering its way underneath
my door it was one of those
things those x people trying to get in
that'd be bad enough but then it started
talking to me kyle
my darling
why are you all cooped up down here
it isn't healthy
you ought to come outside sweetie
get some sun
my darling
it was my mom well it used to be i guess
she wanted to come over and visit me
needless to say i got out of there and
i've got no intention of going back that
place is dead to me now i don't even
want to think about that voice ever
again both her and so
not her so now i'm on the move i guess
i'll speak to you again when i stop stay
safe out there day 28 i decided it was
best to make my way out of town towards
the fringes the day first broke the
people who were in the most densely
populated areas were the first to go
that's why i decided to hole up in a gas
station last night just to avoid the sun
but during the night people came not x
people actual people they showed up in a
jeep outside the building refueled and
then came in they were wearing black
cobbled together outfits and hockey
masks they were all either carrying
baths or axes too you can probably
understand why i didn't decide to
introduce myself when they busted their
way in i concealed myself in a broom
closet while they searched around it was
nerve shredding i'd never been more
thankful in my life when they left day
29 coming up on a month of this madness
after the incident at the gas station i
realized i needed some kind of defense
it's not just the sun and those
creatures i need to worry about just
like the old world people could be
dangerous here too that's why i snuck
into a gun store in the dead of night
some of it had been looted but much like
the supermarket near my house there was
plenty still here the walls were covered
in all manner of rifles shotguns and
even sub-machine guns i heard somewhere
that revolvers are more reliable and
easy to maintain than other types so
since i'm a gun novice i grabbed a
revolver and stuffed my pockets with as
many bullets as i could carry let's hope
i never have to use any of them day
30.
do i get to call this a month of
survival i mean if we're talking
february i'd be a month in already
what a horribly dubious honor that is i
saw something disgusting last night and
i thought i'd share it just to get it
off my mind
last night as i was moving through the
wilderness i saw a group of other
survivors gathered around a campfire i
remained scarce but approached just to
see what was going on still carrying my
revolver just to be safe but the people
around the campfire were eating
something and when i saw what they were
eating i swear to god i almost threw up
they were chopping up one of the ex
people hooking the parts over the fire
and eating it day 31 a month by anyone's
definition ever since seeing those
others eating one of the ex people i've
had trouble eating even normal food
myself my stomach aches and my throat
burns
god i feel so weak i keep laying down
and resting i know i need to eat soon if
i want to survive to day 32 but every
time i think about eating i think about
the gooey flesh of the ex people
sometimes i wish i hadn't survived this
long i'll eat soon i just need to sleep
first day 32 243 if you live this long
you really ought to be proud of yourself
i've seen thousands of those slimy x
people and there's probably millions
more out there well maybe even billions
if we're being honest with ourselves
here am i just talking into the void
here is there even anyone else out there
who's human enough to watch this stuff
maybe i just need to keep thinking about
posterity on the off chance that the
world ever gets better and we reach some
time where children are born again and
all this fades from human memory you'll
still have these stupid pointless little
videos to remember how awful all this
was that way at least i can make myself
believe this all had some kind of i
don't know point so what's happened with
me not much still moving at night
surviving hiding in closets and
underground parking complexes during
daylight down to uh my last few cans so
i'm hoping to hit a supermarket soon god
what a ridiculous way to go starving in
this new world with so many new
interesting ways to die with the x
people things have been a little more
eventful there used to be one blob to a
person but they've started
joining up that's the best way i can put
it things that used to be people and
animals are starting to melt together
getting bigger and bigger they've never
been aggressive but i think it's best to
stay out of their way whatever all this
is about i am streetwise enough to know
that it can't be anything good i'll just
keep moving and i hope you can do the
same whoever the hell you are hopefully
the next time i check in with you it's
with better news than
this day 44 i saw a shootout on the road
last night the people who are left the
ones who are still indeed people are
becoming less human something about
situations like this this sustained
stress and pain and hopelessness it
weighs on you there are no rules in the
post-apocalypse the only thing that can
stop you from doing anything is a bullet
to the head five or six people last
night as afraid and desperate and hungry
as me gunned each other down they did
this for reasons i will never understand
even if i wanted to because there are no
survivors left to tell the tale what a
funny world we live in day 45 i sleep
when i can it's surreal i remember when
i feared the dark and loved bright sunny
days even all this time in i still don't
think i'm used to the switch bean flip
i've been having awful dreams again i'm
still running in them with a deep red
sun shining up in the sky being chased
by a mountain of flesh the size of mount
everest it's swallowing up the city
behind me and it keeps getting closer no
matter how fast i go i just i can't
escape it'll get me eventually something
terrible is going to happen soon i just
know it day 46. i
shot a man today i don't know if you
survived i hope you lived we encountered
each other inside an abandoned building
i i think we spooked each other and
didn't have any time to ask if we were
friends or foes we were too afraid
either way we both drew our weapons and
i was faster than he was when my
revolver discharged and he collapsed i
ran off simon would come up in a few
hours and i just needed to find another
place to hide
what the hell have i become i don't know
how things could get any worse than this
not to self in the future don't even
dare to think how could things get any
worse because if i've learned anything
since this whole nightmare started that
is never a rhetorical question welcome
to the space between day 47 and day 64.
if you're still alive and watching this
i am so sorry so i've got good news and
i've got bad news i'll give you the good
news first i've seen more people who
haven't been changed yet and the bad
news last time i saw them they were
being dragged out into the light kicking
and screaming in the tendrils of one of
those horrible flesh monsters i was
telling you about last time they've
gotten a lot bigger now and when i told
you they weren't aggressive well um
yeah i spoke a little too soon i can't
just sleep during the day like i used to
these monsters and that's what they are
now they're monsters not people anymore
they patrol they hunt they actively
enter buildings searching for hiding
places searching for people they can
drag out into the light i've seen it
with my own two eyes second they're out
they'll just start melting and fusing
with the mass making it even bigger
adding another voice to the course and i
hate myself because every time i've seen
it happen all i can think is thank god
that's not me
god i wish i could do something to help
to save them but that's not the world we
live in the second they touch the light
it is already over i wouldn't be helping
anyone by adding my flesh to one of
those things i don't want them using my
body to get to other people there's only
one thing i can do now keep moving at
night stay hidden get away from
population centers i've realized where i
need to go now i've still got a distant
memory of those broadcasts in the
earlier days of the event the scp
foundation i noted down coordinates to
the nearest facility they had on the
books and if i'm honest nearest is only
a relative term because at this rate
it's gonna take me an eternity to get
there but
it'll be worth it in the end when i get
there it'd all be worth it if i can at
least get some answers at least know why
the world turned into this hell those
scp folks seem better prepared for this
than anyone so even if they can't fix
this they've at least got to have
answers right somebody needs to have
answers i really want to believe that
when the sun goes down i'll start moving
again if you're watching this wish me
luck i don't have much food left i'll do
what i can
yeah hey i realize i'm not looking great
right now but trust me you should see
the other guy day
65 today 86. never thought i would make
it this far but hey life's just full of
surprises before you ask and i mean why
would you ask it's not like i can hear
you it wasn't one of the monsters that
did this to me it was another person
just like me desperate hungry afraid the
one difference between me and them was
the fact that they had a handgun and i
didn't they asked for all the food i had
and when i wasn't exactly forthcoming
they decided to shoot me and steal the
last of my food while i lay bleeding on
the ground oh well okay that's not
entirely fair they did leave me with one
protein bar which i had to cave and eat
a couple days ago
since then i've just been foraging with
little food i can from plants along the
way during my nighttime walks but
it isn't much and my wound is giving me
grief i sure hope they've got doctors at
this scp foundation or otherwise
i may be
even more out of luck than i thought
here's the good news for you since i
know how much you love that i'm not far
off of the foundation site now even in
this state i'm probably only a couple
weeks away i think maybe i can will
myself to live that long at least
if i can get some answers just
before i die then i can be happy and
sometimes folks that's all you can ask
for
final stretch let's hope i see you again
on the other end stacey i'm here i'm
here
the scp foundation on day 100. but
i don't understand where is everybody
hello is anybody there goddammit why is
nobody here i i don't understand they
were meant to have the answers they were
meant to know what was going on here but
they're all gone too
it isn't fair it isn't fair
is this it is it all just over the end
of the freaking world as we know it
it isn't fair
it isn't fair
wait are those footsteps hello yes hello
i'm over here who's there oh my god what
the hell is that thing
no
no get away from me oh god
disgusting
dr jack bright was having the second
worst day of his life and things weren't
about to get any better he ran down the
main hall of sight 19 medallion jangling
against his chest all around him sirens
blared and warning lights flashed a
stark threatening red he cursed and
muttered under his breath just an hour
ago things had been under control
neat and orderly standard running
operations and now they were staring
down the barrel of both a broken
masquerade scenario and a potential xk
class end of the world scenario and on a
more personal level four of the meanest
nastiest and deadliest anomalies were on
his tail they breached containment
compromised site security and now they
were out for revenge what was happening
how had this group of anomalies gotten
out and why were they all after dr
bright and most importantly of all how
could everything have gone to hell in a
hand basket so fast let's rewind the
clock and see the morning had begun in
the break room dr bright was enjoying a
nice cup of hot coffee and a danish
watching the news it was by all accounts
an incredibly boring day the reports
were economic figures a few dry
statistics about unemployment and then
live coverage of a presidential press
conference on the white house lawn dr
wright was halfway through a thought
about how he'd hated his brief period of
time inhabiting the body of george w
bush and running the country when the
president started melting over his
podium on live tv as well as his guards
and the press corps and the camera
people it was a sight so shocking and
made dr bride drop his coffee cup and
almost drop his danish he slipped out
his phone and fired off a text to 05-1
the leader of the o5 council simply
saying we may have a problem to which he
received the quick and emphatic reply
you think
dr bright started frantically changing
the channel he wanted to know if some
anomalous troublemaker had just melted
the president and those around him
perhaps to destabilize the us government
that be a textbook chaos insurgency move
or if they were looking at something
considerably more dangerous and
considering every single channel dr
bright changed to started displaying a
signal interrupted message now was
probably not the time to be optimistic
it was here the big one the one they'd
all been waiting for
battle stations engage across site 19
the protocols were enacted to put
everything on total lockdown nobody in
nobody out it was lucky for everyone
inside that hadn't already been exposed
that this protocol also involved the
automatic shuttering of every single
window in the building dr bright and a
crack team of senior researchers and
administrators gathered in the sites
command center and opened up a live
video link to 05-1 they might make some
sense of all this chaos now and figure
out a good battle plan so
what's the situation boss dr bright
asked 05-1 let out a deep rattling sigh
well jack things are about as bad as
they'd ever been so i'll try my best to
take inventory a quarter of the council
is gone they got exposed and stopped
reporting in during the initial shift
that includes 05-9 on the orbiting base
given she probably got the most direct
exposure a senior administrator raised
their hand and asked
exposure to what sir 05-1 took a grave
pause before saying
sunlight that seems to be what we're up
against here the one common denominator
that seems to connect everyone
experiencing these anomalous effects is
direct sunlight exposure it causes
people to take on a kind of
gelatinous state and it isn't just
people either it's all living anomalies
too
something about this new sun thing it's
almost like it cancels out all previous
anomalous effects the only anomalies
that seem to be exempt are the ones who
aren't even made out of flesh dr bride
who had a tendency to make jokes as an
emotional defense mechanism when things
got tough chimed in with on a
semi-related note anyone here feel like
taking the lizard for a walk the few
nervous chuckles in the room were cut
off by 05-1 slamming his fist against
the table over the video link everyone
fell into a deathly silence damn it jack
this is no laughing matter the
foundation and the rest of the human
race is decimated right now we're
looking at billions dead already or at
least changed and even our people a good
portion of them are reading the tea
leaves and abandoning their posts to
spend what could be their last hours
with their families it is imperative we
take control of this situation right now
it may be our last chance so get your
asses in gear and make it happen and
with that the video link was cut off and
the ragtag leaders of site 19 got to
work taking what they knew about this
lethal new scenario dr bright had his
subordinates record and release one of
the most significant videos of the 21st
century or perhaps even all of time to
be broadcasted on every communication
channel the foundation could possibly
hijack tv
radio social media youtube twitch all
global news outlets the scp foundation
was going public people all over the
world huddled in the dark terrified of
the horrors they'd seen through windows
or out of the safety of shady corners
noticed that all the screens around them
started playing the same thing in
perfect synchronicity it was flashing
red with an unfamiliar logo while a
commanding voice droned on with the only
instructions that might give them hope
for survival this is a public service
announcement from the scp foundation we
are commandeering all broadcast channels
and frequencies to deliver a vital
message avoid sunlight at all costs
cover your bodies thoroughly and follow
the instructions on the screen to reach
the nearest operational scp foundation
containment site back at site 19 dr
bright and everyone they had left were
preparing for a sudden influx of
refugees from the outside any members of
d-class personnel who weren't
psychopathic killers were deputized as
honorary foundation personnel and
brought in to convert empty wings into
sleeping and living areas bride who is
still trying to hold on to some
semblance of humor in this dark time
thought to himself well if i knew we
were going to be entertaining guests i
would have cleaned up the place a little
more you know maybe bought some new
throw pillows and a scented candle or
two and make no mistake it was indeed an
incredibly dark time it had only been a
few hours since the phenomenon started
and already it was hell out there
society had already effectively
collapsed during the chaos the streets
were filled with the shambling remains
of melted nightmare people the sun shone
far above like some all-powerful tyrant
gazing its single deadly eye down on all
of humanity for billions upon billions
of years it had given this solar system
life now all it had for them was death
and destruction for those trapped
outside there was only one hope of
survival getting to one of these scp
foundation containment sites at least
those people somehow knew what was going
on here little did these unfortunate
refugees of a horribly and irreparably
changed world know that all was not well
in the world of the scp foundation as
the hours marched on broken masquerade
scenario and possible xk aside it seemed
to dr bright that they actually had a
handle on the situation all things
considered and what's more the night was
about to fall allowing for free movement
outside this would be a boon for people
hoping to reach site 19 with minimal
risk of exposure but refugees wouldn't
be the only thing coming to site 19 that
day hours earlier and miles away
something terrible happened at
containment area 25b an extensive and
heavily guarded containment site with
only one inmate during the initial panic
of the event that they were now
codenaming when daybreaks many of the
guards were exposed and several others
abandoned their posts in panic knowing
that the world as they had all grown to
know it had come to an end this left the
place grievously underguarded 200 meters
under the sea in the true heart of the
containment area an obsidian coffin was
surrounded by a confused and terrified
skeleton crew and the term skeleton crew
was about to take on a far more literal
meaning as the obsidian coffin they were
trying in vain to keep contained
started to rattle fast forward by 20
minutes and every single member of
foundation personnel at containment area
25b was dead and scp-076-2
the legendary immortal warrior abel was
standing in the ruins of the base while
it would be easy to write abel off as a
mindless killing machine because of the
sheer ferocity he brings to a battle the
reality couldn't be further from the
case he had the kind of tactical
intelligence that human supercomputers
wouldn't develop for another several
centuries if the world hadn't ended
already from the visual evidence he'd
gleaned upon escaping he already knew
that sunlight had turned deadly turning
everyone who was exposed into these
feeble blobs so if he hoped to continue
his killing frenzy elsewhere he'd need
to create his own shade during transit
that would be simple enough with a cruel
smirk abel picked up one of the
reinforced blast doors he'd so easily
burst through earlier the sheer weight
of it would have crushed a mortal man
but for abel this was little more than a
light workout he lifted the door above
his head like a parasol bathing himself
in the cool shade before taking off at
impossible speeds he'd remembered a lot
from his days under the foundation's
employ as part of the disastrous
pandora's box mobile task force and one
of those things was the location of site
19. there'd be plenty of warriors for
him to send to their makers there back
at site 19 where abel would very shortly
arrive dr bright and his team were
helping the first wave of outsiders into
the confines of the building at first it
had seemed like a good idea something
they could sustain but now dr bright was
starting to worry about all the
practical considerations how would they
keep potentially thousands or even tens
of thousands of people fed clothed and
watered for an extended period of time
sure they had the infinite pizza box but
pizza for three meals a day for weeks on
end was a fast track to everyone here
dying of scurvy these new worries were
interrupted by a siren that signaled
familiar ones there had been a
containment breach in several cells in
the humanoid containment wings some of
the low-risk or even friendly humanoids
like scp-343
aka god had been led out to assist in
gathering survivors from the nighttime
chaos outside that meant anyone still
locked up really really really needed to
stay locked up in other words it was
very bad news dr bright cursed under his
breath and instructed his subordinates
to keep focusing on the refugee
situation he shouldered an assault rifle
and took off into the bowels of the site
hoping he could at least head off the
escapees until some guards or mobile
task forces from smaller sites could
reach site 19 and help him in getting
them fully recontained now this is just
typical he thought to himself when it
rains it pours we can never catch a
break around here can we i should have
followed my dreams and become a
competitive ice dancer then i never
would have dr bride's self-pity was
interrupted by a brutal punch to the
side of his head which laid him out
against the wall he turned vision
swimming and raised his assault rifle
hoping to find a target in the blur
that's when an obsidian blade swung at
impossible speed and cleaved his gun in
half he could feel his breath hitch in
his throat as his vision re-centered
itself and he saw the imposing tattooed
figure of abel standing above him
wielding one of his trademark swords his
dark eyes were burning with deadly
intent hello jack he said long time no
see
i imagine i don't need to remind you who
i am
abel laughed and dr bright felt his
muscles tense in rage of course he knew
abel not only had the homicidal maniac
been a consistent thorn in the
foundation side since day one but he'd
also been the one to change dr bright's
life forever it had been able who had
killed him as a junior researcher when
he was first carrying the
scp-963 medallion it was able who had
cursed him with this terrible
immortality dr bright despised him to
his core i'd like you to meet a few
friends i made since i got here jack
abel said gesturing into the darkness of
the hallway who said i was bad at
teamwork it was like something out of a
nightmare first
scp-106 stepped forward dripping with
that terrible black tar his face twisted
into a manic grin that foretold inhuman
tortures to come then came
scp-953 the devilish polymorphic
humanoid claws and fangs bared tails
swaying and then bafflingly scp-2430
the immortal hitler clone dr bright
tried to move but found the tip of
abel's sword right in front of his face
it's funny jack abel said you are an
anomaly who kills to live how many
people have worn your little necklace
and yet you can swan around as you
please while we rot away in containment
we think it's time for a little payback
right not it that makes sense i guess
but why is he here he pointed to the
immortal hitler clone who sneered as
usual he thinks you're jewish said the
polymorphic humanoid in korean clearly
that wasn't korean but here we are dr
bright rose uneasily to his feet
honestly surprised that abel was
allowing him to do so he was lucky in a
sense it perhaps took a being as strong
as able to hold these others at bay as
much as dr bright despised the man he
offered a much quicker and more painless
death than the old man or the
polymorphic humanoid it wouldn't be
anything he hadn't experienced before
after all life could be a sick joke
sometimes so what's the plan you're
gonna kill me again dr bright asked the
four nightmarish anomalies all began to
laugh
well in the end yes abel said but the
world's gone to hell you people aren't
in control here anymore so we can take
our time we will slaughter you and
everyone else in here if i were you
i'd run jack he didn't need to be told
twice jack ran for his life too scared
to even look behind him as the sound of
footsteps got louder the only way things
could possibly get worse is if he
somehow admits to all this suddenly
developed a hernia and the way this day
was going he really wouldn't have been
surprised dr bright turned a corner and
somehow the polymorphic humanoid was
already there standing in front of him
she gave a girlish giggle and swiped at
him leaving four ragged claw marks on
his chest dr bright winced in pain and
started running in the other direction
he reached an adjoining hallway and
booked it for the armory hoping there
he'd get some serious firepower but
scp-106 suddenly phased through the wall
next to him grabbing dr bright by his
lab coat and throwing him against the
opposite wall with a flick of his wrist
bright scrambled to discard the coat
already being eaten away by the old
man's caustic fluids the old man was
just watching him and chuckled faintly
amused by the whole affair these damn
anomalies were in control now dr bright
got up and kept running the one saving
grace was the fact that all of these
anomalies were too sadistic to outright
kill him just yet so he still had the
faintest of chances he ran into the
break room tipping over shelves
bookcases and furniture to obstruct the
path behind him ever so slightly that's
when he heard the door behind him open
followed by a wave of furious german
expletives as the immortal hitler clone
entered the room to give chase however
moments later hitler fell to the ground
clutching his foot and wailing in agony
you see due to the circumstances of his
creation joseph stalin sarkic wizards
there's a whole thing we really can't
get into it now he felt pain at three
times the intensity of a normal human
being libra god i'd stopped my toe
he yelled dr bride kept running from the
break room he entered the hallway that
would lead him back to the main barracks
perhaps there he could get some
reinforcements and then maybe he could
his thoughts were once again cut off by
abel suddenly appearing and grabbing him
by the throat his grip was impossibly
strong dr bright was already seeing
stars think you could get away that
easily able hissed with horrifying
strength abel slammed dr bright up
against one of the shuttered windows he
struck it with such a force he broke
through the shutter and the glass behind
it sailing down to the ground outside
they were lucky it was night time or
this all would have been over already
abel soon followed him down cracking his
knuckles and assuming a fighting stance
up on your feet jack abel said i won't
kill a man lying down no honor in that
jack rose feeling pain in every inch of
his body up against a seven foot tall
jacked monster of a man with thousands
of years of fighting under his belt he
stood mathematically zero chance but
perhaps he could at least get some licks
in he ran at abel screaming with years
of pent-up rage and tried to attack him
with a flurry of blows but not a single
one landed abel was able to dodge every
punch and returned them with a force
comparable to being hit by a runaway
train he knocked dr bright to the ground
and started beating him relentlessly all
these lives i've given you all this
extra time and still you haven't learned
how to fight pathetic
abel roared punctuating his words with
blows perhaps in a thousand years you
might last 60 seconds against me you are
a waste of your gift
dr bright could already feel the life
leaving his body when something new
entered the equation
he could barely make it out through his
bloody swollen eyes but something huge
was coming towards them it was like
flesh from so many of the melted people
had coagulated into some huge
mountainous blob it was a site so
remarkable and horrifying that even abel
was distracted and dr bright took
advantage of the one chance that it gave
him he took off his medallion and threw
it at the mass the life left his old
body as scp-963
deleted the collection of tortured minds
that had made up the terrible flesh
monster and replaced them with only one
dr jack bright he felt new immense
monstrous strength well up through him
he was in the body of a true abomination
and all of its power was his now how
about a round two abel he thought the
ancient warrior produced a pair of ebony
swords as dr bright sent a swarm of
fleshy tendrils at him abel was quick
slicing off many of them but there was
only so much he could take soon dr
bright's new body was grabbing abel's
every appendage holding him in place as
he struggled with all his anomalous
might but now dr bright's rage had
meaning with his new power to back it up
he'd get a little revenge at long last
time to go back in the box abel it took
longer than it would for any mortal man
but eventually it happened all the same
sprite pushed and pulled in every
direction applying every kind of
pressure leveraging every ounce of his
terrible new mass onto abel's body until
crunch dr bright relaxed his new body in
a final cathartic relief dropping abel's
corpse to the ground there was no
denying after everything that happened
that it felt really really really good
the world may have ended but at least dr
bright got one win today
shirley woke up screaming louder than
usual this time bae shirley's wife
bolted upright as though someone had
just run a 20 000 volt charge through
her her dirty hand clasped over
shirley's mouth until the awful sound
stopped she whispered baby it was just a
dream just a dream shirley fell into a
terrified silence trying to regulate her
breathing they'd been hiding in an
abandoned apartment block for three days
now waiting for the roads to clear so
they could take the chance and move
forward
keeping closer to the ground scuttled
over to one of the smashed out windows
she stared down onto the street 30 feet
below midnight no stars cars crashed up
against one another from the initial
panic and thank god none of those things
down there she breathed a sigh of relief
and returned to shirley gathering her up
in her arms and giving her a reassuring
squeeze her body was still trembling
what happened in this one they asked
shirley exhaled and closed her eyes we
were close now she said we're so close
bae it was the dream that began this
journey the quest for the last safe
place initially bae had thought it was a
fool's errand there were no safe places
in this world anymore nowhere that the
sun or its terrible monsters hadn't
touched but surely insisted otherwise
she'd seen it in her dreams a place of
almost mythical wonder a vast and
complex facility away from the light
site 19. shirley and bay grabbed their
backpacks and shrugged them on it was
best to set off now get a few hours of
walking under their belts and find some
shelter before the sun came back up in
the meantime all they needed to do was
avoid the monsters lurking out there it
was an interesting trade-off once upon a
time years and years ago when the sun
changed there had been billions of those
things they were people ones until the
new light touched them and turned them
into these slimy abominations there was
a time you couldn't look out your window
without seeing hundreds of them
slithering past you then they started
coagulating becoming these huge
mountainous masses of gloopy melted
flesh it was nice that there were fewer
now made them easier to avoid easier to
sneak around but if one of those things
found you you were dead or more likely
you were about to be something so much
worse than dead the two women trekked
down the side of the road keeping to the
shadows even in the dark they were on
the edge of the city now and it wouldn't
be long until they were in the
wilderness pro being away from a
population center meant to lower odds of
being attacked by one of those monsters
gone fewer places to hide when the sun
came up in the meantime all they could
do was keep walking and home it was an
almost supernatural mixture of luck and
skill that had gotten them this far
they'd known each other for four years
when day broke and everything went to
hell but they'd only been married for
about a month they'd been a hell of a
post-honeymoon wake-up call so many had
been changed in the initial panic and so
many more had been destroyed by what
came after but these two weren't just
anybody in fact it was the specific
combination of skills and knowledge
these two possessed that kept them alive
for this long in the world that came
before bay had been a soldier who done
two tours abroad and seen active combat
multiple times and shirley had been a
doctor rising through the ranks of a
local hospital between them they could
fight for and heal one another despite
everything and in those early years
that's all it had been they were always
moving always avoiding the terrors
outside and the tyranny of the sun it
avoided the dangers that had destroyed
so many others but they'd never dared to
hope hope was lofty impractical it got
people killed they'd only ever tried to
survive the immediate avoidance of death
was a practical goal anything else was
just confetti until of course shirley
had started having the dreams some were
just fragments like sifting through a
stack of photographs in the middle of a
deep fog others were full narratives
like movies in her head viewed in the
first person but all of them were about
the same thing she and bae needed to
make it to a place they called site 19.
something about it was familiar like a
thing she'd heard years ago perhaps from
those strange broadcasts that were on
every tv screen during the initial chaos
oh and of course there was one more
element in the dream the one thing that
made it seem more like a nightmare in
this part of the dream she was already
in sight 19 and walking down a long dark
hallway somewhere far away from the sun
there are a series of heavy reinforced
doors along the wall next to her each
one of them had a number on them
advancing as she got further down the
hall zero two nine zero three zero zero
three one
two
that's when she'd hear the voice
that awful terrible
voice
surely
oh
shirley
come
closer don't you want to see my face
i'm smiling surely
i'd like for you
to see it she'd reach the door marked
zero three five at which point the door
slowly creaked open even after all the
terrifying things they'd seen in the new
world this somehow paralyzed her with
fear every time it was a kind of dread
she'd never experienced before something
that looked like black water would start
seeping out from the opening door then
footsteps getting closer a shambling
figure would emerge from the open door
it was hard to make it out fully in the
dark but somehow she just intuitively
knew what was coming towards her it had
a stark white face like a mask with
nothing but darkness where the eyes
should be
down below the body seemingly heavily
injured and dripping with the same black
water was one she recognized
her own she couldn't move the masked
figure this masked version of her kept
getting closer dripping with more and
more of that black water it was
shaking almost vibrating then she
realized it was laughing
[Music]
see you soon shirley
it said can't wait for you and bae to
visit and that was when she woke up
screaming somehow despite the grim
ending some part of shirley knew that
she and bey needed to get to site 19.
only there would she be safe and perhaps
even find the answers about how all this
horror had even transpired they were
already risking their lives out here
every day wouldn't it be worth it to
find the truth the duo continued to
trudge through the night it was they
think their lucky stars a relatively
uneventful journey they encountered one
of the flesh beasts on the edge of town
but they were able to hide inside a
nearby bus depot until it slithered on
gibbering incoherent madness after
waiting to make sure it was gone the duo
left the city and ventured out into the
badlands shirley continued to insist
that the legendary psych 19 from her
dreams was definitely close by now bay
looked up to the sky and chimed in i
hope you're right honey for you and me
are fried eggs shirley and bae walked
for another several hours each becoming
more slightly anxious that the sun would
rise before they reached ample cover and
everything they worked for would be
taken away from them the terror
persisted until against all odds a huge
black shape started to emerge along the
horizon the side of it made shirley's
eyes widen in amazement that's it bae
she said site 19 just like it was in my
dreams they passed the chain-link fence
around the perimeter approaching this
large seemingly abandoned building like
it was the lost city of el dorado bay
was astonished she loved shirley of
course and had faith in her beliefs but
something about a place prophesized in a
dream actually being real was honestly
nothing short of a miracle the two of
them approached the fortified front door
and heaved it open together against all
odds they could see light inside the
building they still had power here
nowhere had power anymore maybe this
place really was salvation after all as
the two closed the door behind them they
noticed that the windows all around them
were shuttered it must have been some
precautionary measure against the new
sun smart whoever these people were
they'd thought ahead they'd have some
kind of preparation for all of this so
bae couldn't help but wonder where had
they all gone now as the two ventured
deeper into the building bae unholstered
a handgun that she'd been keeping in her
jacket it was no good against the flesh
monsters but it was a worthwhile
deterrent against other desperate people
out on the road lucky for them she
hadn't needed to fire it yet other than
the power being on somehow the place
seemed abandoned they traveled from room
to room offices filing areas what seemed
like laboratories libraries rest areas
there was no real indication of what
these people whoever they were actually
did around here after searching through
a few different files all written in
almost incomprehensible shorthand in
code shirley at least found a name to
put to these people the scp foundation
was it some kind of charity they
ventured deeper until they found a hall
marked d-class bunks inside they found
bunk beds stacked on top of each other
enough to hold hundreds of people they
wondered aloud whether this was some
kind of secret paramilitary outfit it
was the one thing that might explain
everything they'd seen here today and in
all fairness she was at least partially
right okay ladies hold it right there
shirley and bay turned around to see a
man in an orange jumpsuit standing a few
feet behind them he was carrying an
assault rifle and training it on both of
them he was a tall imposing man and yet
he was shaking bailored her gun neither
she nor shirley said a word you're human
right he said voice trembling slightly
what shirley replied just answer the
damn question there was a tense pause
where nobody there seemed to know what
might happen to them next the stranger's
finger started curling around the
trigger it was bae who broke the silence
we look human don't we she said another
moment passed the gun rattled in the
stranger's hands he exhaled and lowered
the barrel taking a more relaxed stance
sorry he said can't be too careful kind
of stuff they used to keep in here it'd
give you nightmares i'm mike by the way
he approached tentatively shaking
shirley and bay's hands just to prove to
them that he wasn't the kind of guy who
liked to gun down random women he asked
them whether they were hungry and when
they told them they hadn't eaten
anything but protein bars in over a week
he told them he was about to show them
something incredible the site 19 break
room not long after that surely bae and
mike were all sitting around enjoying
some defrosted hot pockets at that
moment no three-course meal cooked up by
a five-star chef could ever even compare
as they ate together mike told his story
the people who used to run this place
believe me they were nut jobs sure back
in the day i wasn't such a nice guy me
and some other knuckleheads we needed
the money so we robbed a few places
people got caught in the crossfire next
thing i know i'm on death row and then
these men in white coats came and told
me i could get a commuted sentence if i
came and took part in some
experiments that's how they got me into
their house of [ __ ] right here if
shirley and bay hadn't lived through the
apocalyptic hell of when daybreaks they
might have not believed mike he told
them about how this scp foundation used
to use humans in experiments subjecting
them to all the monsters they had locked
up down here there was this giant
reptile that couldn't be killed some
freaky statue that would snap your neck
if you stop looking at it but the one
that frightened him the most the one
that haunted his dreams ever since he
got here the mask surely said aloud lost
in thought mike was taken aback how had
she known what he was going to say it
did nothing to reduce his fear when she
told him that she'd been dreaming about
the mask for over a month now stark
white with black water dripping from it
everyone was silent for a moment bay and
mike just stared at surely equal parts
amazed and frightened mike cleared his
throat and told shirley that in the
years that had passed since day broke
the population of psych-19 had slowly
dwindled monsters had escaped the flesh
beasts had slithered in and taken others
over time most of the staff had either
died changed or left all that was left
here was
him and the mask luckily for him he'd
never been directly cross-tested with it
because those who got tested with the
mask never came back sometimes he could
hear it whispering in his dreams trying
to leak itself into his mind drip by
drip poisoning his soul the one saving
grace was that being a mask it couldn't
exactly walk up and tap you on the
shoulder all you needed to do was stay
away from it and you'd be fine the mask
couldn't hurt you on its own
the three of them carried on talking for
the last hours of the morning night had
become day and day had become night it
was the easiest way to survive these
days or at least survive as yourself
bane surely told mike how they'd met in
college all those years ago mike told
them the story of how he managed to
survive by hiding in a broom closet
while some gangly white monstrosity
chased down and slaughtered the rest of
his bunkmates the tiredness took them
all again and they decided to bed down
in the d-class bunks they were more
comfortable than the bed rolls that
shirley and bay had been sleeping on in
abandoned buildings for the last year or
so to mike this place had been a living
hell once upon a time but now for a
brief period in this terrifying new
world it could be heaven shirley drifted
off to uneasy sleep trying her best to
ignore the whispers in what only felt
like a few moments her eyes fluttered
back open she was in a new place but one
that felt oddly familiar a long dark
hallway bordered on one side by a series
of iron doors she turned her head
slightly eyes still adjusting to the
darkness the number on the door next to
her read zero two seven further down the
hall shirley saw a dark figure standing
tall shoulders broad and back erect as a
ballet dancer as her vision came back
into focus she saw a shock of orange it
was mike wearing that same orange
jumpsuit he was standing about 10 or 15
feet away staring in the opposite
direction mike surely said operating on
the foggy half-logic of a dream he
didn't respond with growing concern she
started stepping closer mike that's when
she noticed something else black water
pooled around mike's feet the sight of
it stopped her in her tracks and froze
the breath in her throat with an almost
audible creak mike turned around a
grinning white mask covered up his face
hello shirley
it said so lovely to finally meet face
to face eh
i bet you're so glad you ran into me
after all
sleepwalking can be dangerous
shirley screamed and ran in the opposite
direction wasting no time at all she
heard the slow measured footsteps of
mike wearing the mask behind her it was
in no rush it walked like a masked
killer in a horror movie why run the
voice said i've got all day and i know
you can't leave while the sun's up
darling you and your beloved are all
mine it's only a matter of time
somehow despite her being so far ahead
the voice sounded like it was right next
to her ear like it wasn't speaking out
of its mouth it was just talking
directly into her brain with every
syllable her mind started to slow like
the mask's voice was tar seeping in
between the gears soon enough her legs
stopped working shirley was frozen in
place hearing the footsteps of the
masked mike behind her her brain was
flooded with dark thoughts death pain
torture grief the final smothering of
all hopes and happiness there was really
nothing like it like every nightmare
she'd ever experienced being collected
into one terrible elixir and poured onto
her mind so this was what that horrible
mask could do soon enough the masked
mike had passed her and turned to look
directly at her face there was an awful
smell like chemicals and burning flesh
she turned her gaze downwards seeing
that it looked like mike's body was
somehow melting away from all that black
water it was like acid mike was a weak
host the mask said as if it was replying
to her thoughts he won't last much
longer but that's fine i'm looking
forward to taking you for a whirl dear
shirley
and when your hands are mine
you can only imagine the terrible things
i'm going to do to your beloved bae with
them
surely with all her willpower was able
to move her mouth enough to force out
the words don't you dare touch her the
monster laughed just like it always did
in her dream
[Laughter]
that's not your choice to make anymore
it's sad the masked reach for her with
mike's melting fingers fizzling away
with all that black slime getting so
close to caressing her tender cheek all
that awful silence was only broken by
the sound of a soft clicking behind it
then a gunshot passing through the back
of its stolen head the mass turned more
shock than anything to see bae standing
there wielding mike's old assault rifle
and aiming it with deadly accuracy
before the mass could breathe another
poisonous word bay opened fire releasing
a volley of bullets into the last of its
melting body as it staggered back into
the darkened hallway shirley watched an
astonishment as the creature fell mike's
body splattering into a puddle and
sending the mask itself skittling down
the hallway maybe it was just a trick of
the mind but she could swear the mask
was frowning now not smiling bay
breathed a sigh of relief and said i'm
thinking it's probably better if this
place stays abandoned shirley who hadn't
quite regained her speech just yet just
smiled nodded and embraced bay they
shared a kiss just happy to still be
together and alive despite it all come
nightfall they left again in search of
another place the possessive mask
remained there laying on the floor of
some anonymous site 19 hallway just
waiting for some unlucky weak-minded
survivor to wander in and try it on
while some higher level researchers
specialized guards and containment
experts at the scp foundation have fixed
anomalous projects tailored to their
very particular set of skills for many
lower level operatives including junior
researchers guards janitorial staff and
even the dreaded d-classes every day is
showing up spinning the wheel of
misfortune and finding out how you might
die today will you be hacked to pieces
by a murder monster pulled into a portal
turned into a doll eaten alive made into
a living nest by bugs stretched out and
broken drowned exanguinated set on fire
beaten to death by a volley of anomalous
tomatoes because you decided to drop a
cringeworthy dad joke or a rancid pun
there are perhaps only a handful of
anomalies that not only will not harm
you but will actively enrich your life
by getting to spend time with them and
of course chief among these is the
legendary
scp-999 also known by its adorable
moniker the tickle monster we don't need
to get into too much detail in
describing this gelatinous ray of
sunshine his anomalous delightfulness
has made him somewhat of a celebrity
compared to the murderer's row of
terrifying entities and monsters around
him the researcher assigned to him today
was troubled having seen one of his
favorite co-workers devoured by scp-682
the day before getting assigned to
feeding and checking on scp-999 today
was exactly what he needed as he entered
the room several bags of m ms in hand
the creature cooed perhaps sensing his
tension and approached him immediately
the researcher felt a wave of calm and
contentment wash over him the incredible
and rare feeling that perhaps everything
is going to be all right for once 999
rubbed up against his leg as he poured
eminem's into its eager mouth radiating
good vibes the whole time what an asset
what a gift and to think this adorable
little goober was prophesized to someday
save the world that much seemed almost
funny but he was certainly more than
capable of saving the life of someone
who hadn't felt the warmth of internal
sunshine in quite some time and for that
much the researcher was profoundly
grateful he left 999's chamber that day
with a renewed sense of hope for the
future that maybe just maybe they might
be able to pull through to make a
difference to push this crazy ball of
rock we call our home in the right
direction
maybe someday the sun would rise on a
perfect world who would have thought
that a strange sunrise could change
everything emergency sirens went off
across the globe but in every case they
were drowned out by a terrible endless
chorus of screams but below all that
you'll hear another gut-wrenching sound
a low but pervasive sizzling like an egg
on a hot pan as billions of human beings
started to change their states of matter
the scp foundation had fought off and
contained so many seemingly impossible
threats from interdimensional horrors
like the hanged sealed and scarlet kings
to nightmarish mass killers like scp-102
the old man
scp-096 the shy guy and
scp-682 the hard to destroy reptile in
their many battles against the anomalous
they developed the incredible
methodologies and exceedingly advanced
technology but what good would any of it
do when the very center of our solar
system decided in an instant that rather
being the linchpin of our delicate
cradle of life it would instead be the
horrible instrument of all of our
demises
this awful hypothetical was answered
upon the emergence of scp-001
a terrible day also known as when day
breaks in the snap of one's fingers half
the world was plunged into terror and
death rays of stark red light swept
through the streets people lucky enough
to be in the shade or inside buildings
with a view to the outside saw the
people in the streets seize up and begin
to shriek in terrible pain their skin
sagged and their bones liquefied their
bodies dropped down to the ground and
coalesced into gurgling wretching
puddles the color of melted flesh those
who saw this abomination happening would
never forget it it would stay with them
for the rest of their lives it would
endure like a stain on their retinas an
after image burned into the plasma of an
old tv screen but here's a slight
consolation for most of the human race
the rest of their lives wouldn't be that
long the sudden insanity taking over the
world caused the scp foundation to do
something drastic step out of the
shadows metaphorically speaking of
course the legendary foundation motto
had been reversed they would die in the
light so that humanity could live on in
the dark thankfully the very concept of
the day gave them one advantage while
one side of the earth was effectively
doomed the second the process began
the other side had a 12 hour head start
before the sun turned its terrible eye
to them sirens went off in the middle of
the night waking people up groggy
rubbing the sleep from their eyes every
television and radio an internet-enabled
device in their home was playing the
same message direct from the scp
foundation which now had effectively
commandeered the entire us government
along with the rest of the world it gave
them directions to the nearest
foundation containment site and told
them that if they didn't immediately
comply and find their way to safety they
would experience a terrible death by
sunrise and if you're at all familiar
with human beings you've probably
already predicted that they didn't just
calmly wrap themselves up make their way
to their cars and form an orderly line
to the various foundation containment
sites located around them it was in fact
total pandemonium as the solar clock
ticked down slowly marking off the
seconds that anyone outside had left to
live the only human beings with a
meaningful head start began to go insane
in a number of varied and interesting
ways some who took the situation
seriously and acknowledged that the sun
was indeed going to wipe out most of
humanity simply cracked under the
pressure there were those who went into
totally catatonic states rocking back
and forth in the corner and refusing to
respond to any stimuli some became
erratic and violent with unpredictable
behavior that harmed themselves and
others after all what was the point in
acting normally anymore when the
complete crumbling of human civilization
was imminent and their only hope was
some shadowy organization they'd never
heard of some not heeding the warning
seriously enough and prompted by greed
and opportunism tried to take advantage
of the situation financially some
smashed windows of local stores and
looted or broke into the homes of
neighbors who had already fled in hopes
of prolonging their property others were
a little more creative setting up
short-term everything must-go nighttime
fire sales for their brands of essential
oils neurotropics and nutraceuticals
claiming all of them had the power to
ward off or cure the new effects of the
sun others completely denied the
possibility that any of this was real
and claimed that the messages from this
so-called scp foundation were actually
just a front to take away their freedoms
and trap them in underground government
camps they staunchly refused to follow
any of the safety guidelines that the
scp foundation put out claiming if you
try to take away my first amendment rats
you're gonna take away my second
amendment rights while riding around in
their pickup trucks and suvs blasting
kid rocks don't tell me how to live at
ear splitting volumes naturally they had
all melted into screeching puddles of
liquid flesh by sunrise some were not
victims of their own bizarre choices but
were doomed by the sudden terrible fear
and panic of the circumstances
themselves the highways were gridlocked
cars stuck as far as the eye could see
so many had rushed to escape during the
initial wave that means of transport
soon became choke points liked clogged
arteries in a dying man people do
irrational things when they're scared
riots broke out in the streets fighting
killing burning everyone hoping for some
means of meager control over a situation
that had long been out of any of their
hands some were too far away with not
enough time to close the distance what
could they really do but just sit around
and wait to die the hours marched on as
the earth made its slow turn towards the
sun leaving one decimated half in
darkness and the other a sitting duck
for its terrible effects hundreds of
thousands had made their way to the
containment sites and safely gotten
inside but still so many millions were
left outside it was a slaughterhouse one
great big global meat grinder and every
moment that passed the handle turned and
any humans left outside got just that
little bit closer to the grinding
gnashing gears below site 19 being the
largest containment site on the
foundation books also became humanity's
only bastion it was the great hope of
escape from the horrors going on outside
the foundation had figured out so many
ways of counteracting deadly anomalous
forces before given enough time and
enough personnel surely they could
figure out a solution to even this this
was however when the most startling
realization yet swept over all the
survivors those who were melted by the
sudden hostile sun weren't dead they
were very much alive in fact but they'd
been changed in both body and mind what
had once been humans now became terrible
beasts half-melted gelatinous nightmares
that coagulated into even bigger beasts
they got into their head that they were
grateful for the transformation that
they had been liberated from their old
forms in the old world they were
something so much more now and they
wanted everyone else to join them in
their liberation survivors outside the
foundation containment sites were
systematically hunted by these great
masses of altered flesh even though
smart enough to cover every inch of
their bodies with clothes to protect
from the sun to only move at night to
carry weapons were dragged out by meaty
tendrils from their refuge in the
basements and the lightless hearts of
buildings dragged into the searing gaze
of the sun to melt to change to coalesce
into something greater it was the
inevitable fate of all of humanity when
most of the stragglers were dragged out
and changed the flesh masses started
turning their attention to the
foundation containment sites that were
keeping all these poor deluded people
from salvation they mounted offensives
against the bases which the foundation
with what remained of their manpower and
advanced weaponry did what they could to
repel the attacks but every single day
it got harder thankfully for the people
holed up at site 19 there was one
consolation out there to help
scp-999 the foundation was at war with
the sun and its terrible disciples and
contrary to many people's beliefs
it takes more than men equipment and
bullets to win a war 999 provided the
essential element that brought it all
together morale hope the will to go on
even when it seemed like all could be
lost after a long day of battling the
fleshy abominations at the gates
foundation guards mobile task force
members and even civilian volunteers
were drained and traumatized by the
horrors that they'd seen once a day was
over 999 would move among the ranks
cuddling up to them warding off the
despair that was easy to set in during
the downswing of a terrible apocalypse
like this without his presence there
would be no hope of fighting that good
fight so many of them would have given
up walked into the sun and joined the
monstrous force they were fighting after
all they seemed happy enough and it
would certainly be easier 999 had become
once again an indispensable asset to the
scp foundation the solar betrayal may
not have been the scarlet king's doing
well as far as our current intel
suggests anyway but he was playing a
crucial part in saving the world exactly
as predicted 999 didn't fully understand
what was going on outside sometimes why
there seemed to be fewer people as the
weeks went on and why the people there
seemed so sad all the time whenever he
wasn't helping them but he was more than
happy to help whatever the case many of
the humanoid and some even non-humanoid
anomalies which realistically pose no
harm to people inside the site were
released from their containment chambers
they needed everyone and everything they
could get in what seemed like a
hopelessly one-sided fight against the
very concept of being outside many of
the larger vacated chambers were now
filled with refugees from the outside
many of whom had lost everything and
everyone they'd ever known to the
horrors out there 999 made the rounds in
these areas regularly and through the
d-class cots which had been repurposed
into more sleeping areas for the
thousands of desperate and terrified
refugees the adjustment to this new life
and to the knowledge of all secrets that
had been kept from them for all these
years wasn't exactly easy on their
psyches but spending time with that soft
yellow blob that seemed to smell exactly
like their favorite scent from the old
world made everything better he was a
savior in dark times slithering from
person to person giving hope where there
was none people opened up about their
problems and their fears which these
days were remarkably similar and though
999 couldn't reply for many was enough
just to feel like they were being
listened to he was a soft blobby
shoulder to cry on and after day broke
everyone needed a good old-fashioned cry
however one day while wandering the long
dark corridors of site 19 he saw a
different kind of crying it was a woman
with an unfamiliar face probably one of
the rare new refugees bawling her eyes
out to a foundation senior researcher
and an accompanying guard with an
assault rifle hot fat tears were rolling
down her dirty cheeks her shaking hands
clasped in prayer she was begging the
researcher and the guard to let her go
outside she said that her son was still
out there hiding away in the back room
of a bank where she used to work they
got separated she needed to go back and
find him sadly the researcher and the
guard told her that this was out of the
question official orders stated that
anyone outside the base at this time was
to be considered lost letting her go out
there to find her son would essentially
be condemning her to death no human
could go out there safely but of course
scp-999 isn't by any definition a human
what night fell and everyone else was
hunkered down inside 999 found a small
crack in the wall and slithered out of
it it may not have been communicative in
the way most humans were but 999 was
indeed an intelligent being and knew
intuitively that if it left through a
more obvious route its human caretakers
here at the scp foundation might try to
stop it and when it came to saving this
little boy 999 refused to let anyone
stop it 999 slithered out and through
the broken streets there were no bodies
of course it seemed even the dead could
be revived and assimilated through the
power of the sun talk about a mixed
miracle but the broken down world
outside site 19 undeniably reflected the
pandemonium that took place here 999
would need to do his best to find the
little boy trapped out here before the
sun rose he lost a few hours even
finding his way to the nearest town
where it was safe to assume that the
little boy was trapped he saw those
things on the way there those moving
wailing mountains of melted human flesh
each talking and shattering to
themselves in a hundred different dead
voices 999 had been cross-tested with
scp-682
and still those monsters frightened him
he decided it would be best to stay away
from them and make sure that they never
saw him out of here eventually 999
reached the town similarly dilapidated
and broken down in the months since the
world as we had all known it disappeared
in a ray of terrible sunshine more great
jibbering blobs of flesh patrolled the
streets looking for converts to
integrate into their biomass 999 could
only hope it wasn't already too late for
the little boy 999 discreetly slithered
from building to building until it could
identify one as this bank that the boys
distraught mother had been mentioning it
thankfully had some awareness of what a
bank actually was from the years of
stressed foundation employees telling it
about the money troubles they were
suffering outside of work it was another
great example of it paying to listen
eventually it did slither into the
correct building and it heard the
extremely quiet whimpering of the boy
inside it could feel the sadness and the
fear radiating off of him as it was the
creature's natural instinct to help the
needy and to use those signals like a
homing beam to find the scared little
boy he'd hidden inside a broom closet
and was quietly weeping into his hands
he hadn't eaten in days and was only
surviving by drinking the filthy water
from the mop bucket sitting next to him
999 immediately embraced the boy
covering him in its healing energy until
the tears of the boy's face eventually
dried 999 cooed and chirped pleasantly
until the little boy was laughing again
but this momentary joy was soon
interrupted a great heaving weight
dragged itself down the hall outside
both 999 and the boy could sense its
monstrous presence as it got closer they
could hear all those chattering voices
those poisonous whispers when it passed
the door they heard it speaking its
voice practically vibrating with the hum
of malicious lunacy
turn towards the sun
feel it on your face
feel yourself change and sloose and mix
into us
become one with our army of one it must
be so lonely to be you
little flower
walk into the sun and be us
999 and the boy remained silent in the
broom closet for hours as the great
shape patrolled the bank outside
searching for converts for victims at
times it seemed too frightening to even
breathe fearing that would be enough to
make the monster detect them it felt
like an eternity until the monster
eventually did slope off and leave them
in the comforting quiet and darkness of
the closet now they might be free 999
could escort the boy safely back to the
containment site and into the arms of
his terrified mother but when they
opened the door they saw a terrible
sight light in the distance pouring
through the windows in the glass double
doors it wouldn't be safe to go out that
way upon seeing this and putting
together what it meant the boy began to
cry he couldn't take another night in
the closet it was all going to wither
from here until 999 had a wonderful idea
hours later when the foundation's guards
manned the turrets at the entrance of
site 19 waiting for the inevitable
onslaught of the melted flesh creatures
they tensed up seeing a blobbing
gelatinous form slithering towards them
in the distance the guards who'd learned
the hard way from too many lost men that
it was better to be safe than sorry drew
a bead on the distant shape and prepared
to fire when suddenly their superior
race to hand and said wait hold fire
is that 999 and it was they all stared
in astonishment as 999 chipper than ever
came towards them through the sun it
looked as though the opacity of its
yellow cytoplasm had increased but other
than that it was unaffected turns out
the sun couldn't melt what was already
melted the guards parted to allow 999
safe passage into the facility
watching in amazement and once it was
inside 999 slime parted releasing its
contents one very relieved little boy it
seemed through turning up its own
opacity 999 had given the boy safe
passage through the sun and back into
the facility the boy was saved it had
won not long after that there was a
tearful reunion between mother and child
and a brief flash of hope in this dark
and terrible time 999 didn't stop to
bask of course it returned to its duties
keeping up staff morale and helping the
refugees heal from the horrors they'd
seen in its own little way and for a lot
of people
scp-999 really was saving the world or
what was left of it anyway oh and of
course if scp-999 had won your hearts
just like it went ours you'd be pleased
to know that you can purchase your own
adorable high-quality
scp-999 plushy at scp-swag.com
check the link in the description to get
your own trust us having a 999 to cuddle
really does make any apocalypse a whole
lot easier now go check out scp-001 when
daybreaks and scp-999 tickle monster
versus the most evil scps for more of
the two incredibly contrasting anomalies
from today's episode